Rồi mình bắt đầu bữa học luôn nha các em.
Các em đã cầu siêu được xem màn hình.
Rồi chào các em.
Hôm nay buổi học đầu tiên của mình trong
môn cơ xã tầng công nghệ thông tin.
Thì đây là thông tin của cô và cái email
liên lạc của cô.
Thường thì các bạn hay lộn qua cái email
account trên team accountainting này.
Để giảng dạy online thôi chứ nó không
phải email làm việc nữa nha,
thì hôm nay là buổi đầu tiên nên đầu tiên
con sẽ giới thiệu về môn học của mình để
các em nắm rõ các cái nội dung của môn
học, mục tiêu của môn học của mình là gì?
Rồi các phương thức kiểm tra và đánh giá
cũng như là cách thức học và các phần
hướng dẫn về tạo right và lưu trữ.
Mục tiêu của môn học của mình.
Là nó sẽ mục tiêu giới thiệu về bối cảnh
ứng dụng công nghệ thông tin giúp cho các
em có những kiến thức,
nền tảng về hạ tầng cũng như là các năng
lực, đề xuất dự án và kỹ năng thực thi.
Các em có thể hiểu là công nghệ.
Thì thông tin của mình nó không phải là
một,
chỉ có một cái hệ thống phần mềm mà khi
mà mình triển khai vận hành ở các đơn vị
và cơ quan hoặc là công ty á thì nó là
gồm có nhiều thành phần.
Hỗ trợ lẫn nhau thì khi mà các em hiểu rõ
về các kiến trúc,
cấu trúc của các hệ thống và cách thức nó
vận hành trong cái quy trình hoạt động
thực tế thì mình sẽ dễ dàng nắm bắt về
cái ý tưởng và cũng như làm quen với.
Chú ý do vì sao về các môn chuyên ngành
thì đối với một sinh viên công nghệ thông
tin á là khi mà các em vào chuyên ngành
thì đương nhiên là các em sẽ học vô một
cái lĩnh vực mục tiêu topic chủ đề nào
mình **** muốn thường thường thì có thể
là phần mềm.
Phần cứng bên kỹ thuật máy tính hoặc là
về mạng máy tính, truyền thông,
về an ninh mạng, vân vân. Nhưng mà.
Sợ trong cái nhu cầu phát triển hiện tại
và các dự án thì em sẽ thấy là thường
giống như các dự án mà cô tham gia ở
trường thì quy định các dạng cũng sẽ tham
gia các chủ đề, địa đại nghiên cứu thôi.
Mục tiêu hiện tại của các đề tài kêu gọi.
Đại học Quốc gia cũng như của Đại học
Quốc gia Công nghệ hay là một số công ty
hợp tác với Đại học Quốc gia á thì người
ta **** muốn là các cái dự án nó sẽ phải
có liên kết.
Và ứng dụng thực tế phải áp dụng vô một
cái quy trình mà họ kỳ vọng phục vụ cho
mục tiêu và bài toán nào đó họ mà họ ****
muốn,
hoặc là nếu mà đến ở góc độ của bộ khoa
học công nghệ thì đi theo chính sách của
nhà nước là đi phát triển các cái công
nghệ nền tảng.
Công nghệ cốt lõi thì và trong mấy cái
công nghệ nền tảng cốt lõi đó thì nó sẽ
có một cái cảnh.
Thứ nhất là phải có ứng dụng thực tế,
thứ 2 là phải có yếu tố liên ngành là nó
phải đem công nghệ thông tin của mình vô
một lĩnh vực cụ thể chứ mình không phải
chỉ làm một cái hệ thống phần mềm.
Lý theo hướng kỹ thuật thuần túy ở trong
ngành công nghiệp thông tin nên để mình
có thể hiểu về lý do vì sao mục tiêu.
Mang triển khai dự án để sau này khi mà
mình triển khai lên kế hoạch và triển
khai các thành phần khác nhau như là mình
triển khai về hạ tầng mạng rồi đầu tư
phần cứng và các vấn đề liên quan á thì
các em muốn có một cái góc nhìn đó thì
mình cần phải hiểu rõ.
Về cái bức ảnh góc nhìn rộng thì cái môn
này sẽ cho mình góc nhìn rộng hơn.
Còn khi mà vào chuyên ngành thì các em sẽ
có các góc nhìn từ nhỏ hơn,
cụ thể giống như là các em sẽ triển khai
hệ thống phần mềm rồi học về giống như
ngành hiện tại đang hot từ nãy ai thì
mình sẽ phải học về nền tảng.
Liệu về macinanin.
Xong rồi khi mà học xong dữ liệu về
machine anine các liên quan như data,
quản lý dữ liệu, phân tích dữ liệu.
Nhờ các cái công nghệ kỹ thuật nền tảng
nhưng mà sinanening lip aning hoặc là học
transforlearning gì đó thì mình sẽ tới
các cái môn giống như hướng dụng giống
như là em sẽ.
Khai thác dữ liệu ứng dụng cho doanh
nghiệp hoặc là hãy cho bài toán khai thác
trên đường mạng xã hội hay là cho cái bài
toán về dữ liệu MLP,
vân vân thì nó sẽ đi vô cái đó.
Đầu tiên mình cũng sao tơ học tôm hòm.
Xong rồi bắt đầu mình mới vô các cái môn
chuyên ngành mà nó gần tiệm cận giống với
cái khóa đường tốt nghiệp,
á là nó sẽ phải là một cái dự án trong
một bài toán cụ thể trong một ngữ cảnh cụ
thể giải quyết vấn đề gì đó.
Thì để có thể đạt được mục tiêu đó thì
mình sẽ phải đi từ nền đi lên thì cái môn
này nó sẽ cấp cung cấp cho em cái nền về
cái chương trình giảng dạy thì so với các
khóa vừa rồi thì các khóa trước á.
Là học kỳ này là cô vừa lỗi cái chương
trình nên cái nội dung chương của mình nó
sẽ gồm có 8 chương,
8 chương theo cái nội dung mới này của
mình.
Và về cái thành phần đánh giá ở đây là
nếu mình với chuối là thành phần đánh giá
của mình sẽ có 3 thành phần đánh giá cái
các quá trình làm bài đặt trên lớp thực
hành và đồ án cuối kỳ thì cái cách mình
học và cái.
Các của thiết kế của cái môn học này là
các cái nội dung nó sẽ liên quan với nhau
và nó hỗ trợ để cho mình tạo ra cái sản
phẩm cuối cùng là về minh bạch,
thực hành và đồ án.
Thì những các cái phần mà quá trình định
bài tập của dạy tới đâu thì cô sẽ cho các
em bài tập.
Ứng dụng tới đó và khi mình có bài tập
ứng dụng rồi thì mình sẽ vận dụng để mình
hoàn thiện dần cho cái bài thực hành và
đoạn án cuối kỳ tại đặc điểm của cái
ngành và môn của mình,
á là dự án nó sẽ không phải là một dự án
có thể.
Triển khai nhanh trong vòng 1 2 tuần là
nó sẽ xong một giá nhất cũng phải tùy vào
một tháng,
vài tháng thì nó tương đương với một thời
gian mà có một dự án nhỏ tương đương với
thời em học kỳ á.
Nên thường nó làm mình có sẽ hướng dẫn
tới đâu thì cô khuyến nghị là các em sẽ
làm tới đó và sẽ có một cái vài buổi để
cho các em báo cáo tiến trình thì coi các
em làm đúng hướng hay không thì các em
thực hiện dự án.
Nếu mình chưa có kinh nghiệm về quản lý
dự án.
Nên trong cái phần này của các em là cái
trong các buổi thì cô sẽ cho các em làm
bài tập. Cô biết là các em đều đi làm.
Nên mình có bận nhưng mà các phần này của
mình làm theo nhóm,
tất cả đều đánh giá theo nhóm hết.
Nên là các em lập giáo với nhau và mình
nếu mà mình bận thì các em phải có thể
phân công các thành viên trong nhóm để
cùng hỗ trợ qua làm,
tránh trong tình trạng một buổi học là
không có thành viên khác đi học thì nhóm
đó tôi sẽ highlight nha.
Bắt buộc phải có vài thành viên đại diện
cho nhóm đi học là các em có thể xem
video,
trao đổi hoạt động nhóm riêng sao với
nhóm của mình.
Nhưng mà trong cái buổi học để trao đổi
và làm bài tập trên lớp,
cho nhóm thì nhóm đó phải có thành viên
tham dự nha.
Ở và khi mà mình làm á thì cái.
Các bài tập quá trình thì nó sẽ liên quan
ở đây là cô sẽ cho các em hiểu về các
thành phần cần mình cần triển khai và đầu
tư.
Khi cho một công ty doanh nghiệp khi
triển khai nguyên toàn bộ hạ tầng.
Cơ sở tại nguồn thông tin của họ thì nó
sẽ thường khi mà các cái dự án nó sẽ có
quy mô khác nhau ha thường các quy mô mà
giống như chuyên về phần mềm của mình
chẳng hạn thì cái dự án nhỏ thì là mình
sẽ triển khai một cái dự án phần mềm đó.
Ở đây cô sẽ chọn cho các em dự án phần
mềm luôn tại ngành của mình là ngành của
ngành thông tin. Còn ví dụ,
nếu mình là ngành khác thì cô sẽ chọn cái
loại dự án tương ứng,
thí dụ bên an ninh ban an ninh mạng.
Thì các cái dự án sẽ thiên về bảo mật
nhiều hơn ha cũng là các thầy về đó phần
mềm bảo mật.
Còn ở đây của mình là thiên về các cái hệ
thống phần mềm ứng dụng nhiều hơn.
Tại cái chuyên ngành của mình là chuyên
ngành về và phần ứng dụng.
Thì nó sẽ ví dụ giống như kem xây dựng
một cái dự án là xây dựng cái hệ thống
quản lý dữ liệu và hay là cái.
Hay xây dựng nếu cái hoàn hệ hệ thống
quản lý dữ liệu thì nó cũng hơi lớn.
Nếu mà mình vô thì cô cứ nghĩ các em vô
một cái bài toán giải quyết một cái vấn
đề cụ thể,
ví dụ giống như là trong cái quy trình
hoạt động của trường mình thì có các cái
quy trình dành cho cố vấn học tập, hỗ trợ.
Cái quá trình học tập của sinh viên.
Thì kỳ vọng mà hiện tại người ta muốn ứng
dụng mình đang đi theo trọng năng suất
hiện tại luôn,
ha là ứng dụng AI và các cái quy trình
hoạt động làm cho các cái quy trình hoạt
động đó nó thuận tiện, tự động hơn.
Và hỗ trợ tốt hơn.
Thì thay vì theo một cái quy trình bình
thường, một cái hệ thống.
Hỗ trợ sinh viên chỉ cho sinh viên xem
điểm đăng ký học phần rồi coi cái giảng
viên thì có kiểm tra được cái tiến độ học
tập của sinh viên thôi.
Thì mình có thể ứng dụng AI khai thác các
cái dữ liệu về sinh viên,
về cái quy trình học tập của sinh viên.
Để mình có thể dự đoán khả năng tốt
nghiệp của sinh viên đó và mình sẽ có đưa
ra cảnh báo sớm, chẳng hạn,
ví dụ giống như trong học kỳ một hoặc
trong cái tiến trình một học kỳ thì mình
có thể tiến hành tổng kết và phân tích dự
đoán ra cái khả năng bạn đó có tốt nghiệp
và đưa cảnh báo sớm.
Báo cho học sinh, sinh viên nè,
báo cho phụ huynh hay báo cho cô vẫn học
tập thì khi mà đặt ra cái vấn đề đó,
mình làm muốn làm một cái dự án phần mềm
hỗ trợ học tập thông minh chẳng hạn thì
cái phạm vi đó nó sẽ nhỏ lại thì đó phần
mềm.
Còn nếu mà cái dự án của mình lớn hơn
giống như trong cái môn của mình luôn á
là mình sẽ đầu tư luôn tất cả nhiều cái
lớp hạ nền tảng hạ tầng.
Thí dụ mình đầu tư thiên mà bên cạnh cái
hệ thống phần mềm,
nếu bạn nào làm dự án rồi thì các em sẽ
có.
Các bạn báo giá thì mình sẽ biết là mình
sẽ phải đầu tư các thiết bị phần cứng
hoặc là các thiết bị bảo mật vân vân rồi
xây dựng tài nguyên mạng cho nó thì cái
phạm vi đầu tư của mình sẽ lớn hơn và
mình sẽ góc nhìn rộng hơn giống như là
các em muốn phát triển một cái nền tảng.
Dữ liệu để hỗ trợ cho các dự án phát
triển thông minh đang phục vụ cho cái
công ty đó tại công ty đó hiện tại là dữ
liệu chưa đồng bộ.
Nó có thể bị nghẽn và làm cho các cái ứng
dụng về AI hỗ trợ cho khách hàng nó chưa
được.
Tốt thì em muốn xây dựng một hạ tầng về
dữ liệu,
hoàn thiện để hỗ trợ cho các dự án.
Ví dụ AI mới thì cái phạm vi nó sẽ lớn
hơn ha.
Thì trong này cái môn của mình á.
Cô sẽ cho kem nào 2 cái tập làm quen,
mình viết cái thuyết minh đề tài ở đây
của mình và nhớ là thuyết minh đề tài ha
thuyết minh đề tài chứ không phải là
chuyện 2 dự án tại các em chưa có kinh
nghiệm gì để triển khai dự án cả và coi
chỉ cho qua các em làm quen với cái cách
mình lên kế hoạch.
Và mình cách mình viết cái thứ mình đề
tài mình xung quanh nay nằm trong những
kỹ năng quan trọng đối với ngành của mình
luôn á thì cái bài thực hành của mình là
dự án quy mô nhỏ và đầu án cổ kỳ của mình
sẽ là dự án quy mô lớn.
Từ.
Cụ thể,
mấy cái này thì cô mình sẽ học tới đâu và
thầy cô sẽ cho các em là các bài tập liên
quan tới cái phần hướng dẫn thực hành và
hướng dẫn đồ ăn quốc kỳ sao và do các mục
tiêu của nó đều giống nhau nên cái phần
các bài tập của mình chỉ cần đi theo một
luồng là cách mình phân tích.
Vấn đề và viết thuyết minh đề tài còn cái
sau đó các em vận dụng các thuyết minh đề
tài đó,
em viết cho dự án nhỏ hay dự án lớn.
Thì nó chỉ là khác phạm vi thôi ha mình
vận dụng vô thì nó sẽ ra 2 bài thực hành
vào đoạn án cuối kỳ và cái.
Tất cả các hoạt động của mình là một dự
án thì nó phải làm team chứ không thể nào
làm một người nên mình sẽ lập team ha
theo cái này theo sĩ số hiện tại là lớp
của mình ở trong trường hợp này nên các
em sẽ đập nhấn từ 7 đến 15 người và mỗi
nhóm sẽ chọn một nhóm trưởng điều hành
hoạt động.
Động trong cái môn của cô thì cô sẽ điều
phối các em giống như các nhóm dự án của
cô thôi và cô sẽ chấm điểm các em theo
bản kê khai chi tiêu giống như là bình
thường khi mà cô làm dự án thì mình sẽ có
một cái bảng kê khai.
Đây mức các mức khoảng chi cho các thành
viên dựa theo mức độ đóng góp đúng không?
Là mình sẽ có thí dụ mình xung quanh thì
cái dự án của mình,
nếu dự án của mình được đánh giá cao thì
mình sẽ được xung quanh cao.
Còn nếu mà dự án của mình thấp thì mình
xin phân thấp.
Và dựa trên cái mức đóng góp của các
thành viên thì mình sẽ có cái bảng chi
tương ứng thì cái môn này sẽ chấm điểm y
chang theo cái cách đó luôn nha các em là
sẽ dựa trên cái mức độ.
Thực hành của cái thuyết minh đề tài của
các em để cái dự án của em chất lượng
đứng càng đến càng chất lượng thì để mình
tổng điểm mình càng cao.
Sau đó mình sẽ làm cái bản phân công việc
và lập bản chi.
Đánh giá cá nhân cho từng thành viên tùy
theo mức độ đóng góp chứ không phải là
nhóm nào cũng sẽ có điểm như nhau,
ha tùy theo cái bản quan tâm công việc
của mình.
Rồi đó là cái những cái nội dung cơ bản
về môn học của mình.
Các em có chỗ này không rõ không?
Dạ, cô ơi.
Rồi nó đem.
Dạ hiện tại thì nói phím meme thì cũng đã
được phân nhóm sẵn thì theo chỉ số thì
nhóm meme được phân là 12 nhóm thì tụi em
vẫn giữ được cái nhóm đó để làm học theo
cái môn của cô đúng không ạ?
Tùy theo em đạt đúng điều kiện này,
mỗi môn sẽ có quy định khác nhau,
em đạt đúng cái chỉ số này của quy yêu
cầu là được.
Dạ rồi, cảm ơn.
Rồi,
nếu không có vấn đề thì về quy định ha.
Cái này là quy định cơ bản rồi,
mình phải sử dụng làm bài tập thôi ha.
Về cách điều phối để quản lý thì mình sẽ
sử dụng.
Bao right lưu trữ ha và tất cả sử dụng
trên Google Drive để cho cô quản lý.
Ở và tránh cho cái việc xung đột lợi ích
sau này của các thành viên trong nhóm.
Trước đây có đã có nhóm bị rồi,
các em hoạt động nhóm tốt,
hoạt động tốt thì không sao còn có nhóm
các hoạt động các em cãi nhau xong rồi do
cái account lúc ban đầu.
Được sử dụng cao cao cá nhân của một bạn
và bạn nó xóa tài liệu của cả nhóm luôn
thì cô sẽ rất là khó đánh giá nên trong
trường hợp này để mình tránh á là mình sẽ
mỗi nhóm đăng ký một acount riêng để tạo
ra, lưu trữ.
Chọn môn này cho nhóm mình trong môn này
riêng luôn nha các em, sau đó là các em.
Tạo một cái right thì thường cái tạo cái
right xong rồi tạo một cái fonder theo
tên nhóm các em có thể tự tạo nhóm ABC
của các em chữ cái nào cũng được.
Nó là cô sẽ đánh chỉ số lại để quản lý
sao để kem trà sửa tên sao thôi.
Và trong cái fonder nhóm đó thì các em
tạo hay cấu trúc fonder như thế này để
quản lý.
Sau đó các cái bài tập của mình sẽ up lên
ride và nộp đường link.
Nó là cô sẽ làm,
cô sẽ để cho nhóm một làm mẫu và cô hướng
dẫn sau ha,
nhưng mà mình đăng ký một cái account
riêng và tạo phương đơn này trước. Sau đó,
các em share quyền cho các thành viên
trong nhóm và cô.
Cô thì cam với xe quyền cái email này nha,
em tại cái email của trường giới hạn dung
lượng, còn email này của cô,
cô là email của cô đã mua dung lượng rồi.
Thì cô bị quản lý với các em nhiều hơn
thì các em share các em mang lại cho cô.
Đều là có quyền editor và mỗi thành viên
thì viewer để cô kiểm tra.
Rồi các em,
cái chỗ này các em có chỗ nào không?
Nếu ổn rồi thì bây giờ mình sẽ bắt đầu để
cô share cho các em cái like của mình.
Tài liệu của đã up trên Elanning rồi ha.
Rồi.
Kem vào đây nhá,
đây là môn của mình ha thì trên e-lean in
này cái cô.
Thiết kế nó đơn khá là đơn giản,
kem chỉ cần quan tâm thứ nhất là nội dung
khoa học.
Đây là nội dung khoa học của mình.
Tất cả các tài liệu liên quan thì là vào
vai đây để kiểm tra tài liệu lý thuyết,
thực hành.
Tài liệu thuyết hướng dẫn thực hành,
hướng dẫn đồ án.
Danh sách lớp,
còn đây là một cái form 52014, 2024.
Bây giờ nó đã theo form mới rồi.
Đây là một cái hồ sơ thuyết minh đăng ký
đề tài cấp đại học quốc gia.
Các em có thể tham khảo làm mẫu,
cô đưa cái phương tham khảo này không bắt
buộc nha các em.
Em có thể tự thiết kế tại vì khi mà
thuyết minh đề tài của mình,
mình nộp ở mỗi nơi,
nó sẽ có cái form riêng,
nhưng mà dù ở đâu thì nó sẽ có những cái
nội dung quan trọng,
thượng thượng nó sẽ có trong một cái dự
án thì cô đã viết trong cái yêu cầu trong
các phần hướng dẫn.
Thực hành và đồ án rồi ha.
Tiếp theo,
cái phần mình có 3 cột điểm đúng không?
Bài tập trên lớp của mình thì nó sẽ dựa
vào các phần bài tập trên lớp để cô chấm
điểm.
Bài tập thực hành thì nó sẽ dựa vô cái
báo cáo thực hành,
thuyết minh thuyết minh cho dự án nhỏ đó.
Còn đồ án vô học là thuyết minh xin kinh
phí đề tài cho dự án lớn và đồ án môn học
của mình thì khi tới phần nào thì cô sẽ
mở phần đó thôi.
Nói chứ cô không thiết kế theo tuần.
Rồi các em vào đây,
các em sẽ thấy danh sách.
Rồi đây là danh sách lớp của mình.
Cô đã tạo cái danh sách lớp rồi thì bây
giờ mình sẽ làm theo cái hướng dẫn hồi
nãy các em học nhóm và các em coi muốn
các em muốn coi cái yêu cầu á thì bạn nào
quên thì có thể mở ở đây.
Rồi đây là cái yêu cầu lập quy định lập
nhóm nè,
các em tạo nhóm của mình từ 7 đến 15 bạn
và chọn cho cô và bạn nhóm trưởng và đại
diện bạn đó sẽ ghi thông tin nhóm và các
em ghi theo chữ cái ABCD.
Thứ tự nhóm và sau này sẽ là thứ tự báo
cáo của các em luôn là sẽ có do Koranun
quyết định lại chứ mình không có tự để số
nhóm vô nha.
Rồi để cái này và nhóm nào mà mình đã đại
diện một bạn học xong rồi thì các em
xuống slide số 9 thì làm cái nội dung
theo hướng dẫn trong slide cho cô.
Tạo xong rồi và cô coi cái thông tin nhóm
xong rồi thì cô sẽ mở cái bài post để các
em đăng ký đường link và cô kiểm tra sao.
Rồi cái bảo vệ cô sẽ mở quyền,
tạm thời tại cô sẽ mở quyền cho cái.
Từ cái này.
Em nếu mà đã có danh sách lớp sẵn rồi thì
cô sẽ cho các em khoảng 15 phút để các em
hiệu chỉnh nha.
Sau 15 phút thì cô sẽ tắt quyền cho các
em.
Nhớ chuối chỉ nhập đúng cột nhóm này ha
kìm thành viên trong nhóm của mình bạn
nào không có thì báo cô để cô điền vào
không tự ý tự điền nha.
Xong in đậm cho cô mã số sinh viên họ và
tên của bạn giám trưởng.
Là.
Rồi các em bắt đầu đi.
Mới nhắc nhóm 5 không có nhóm 5 nha,
chữ cái,
số nhóm nào là cho cô quyết định nha các
em.
Bạn nào chưa có nhóm thì kem có thể liên
hệ nhắn tin riêng cho các bạn ở trong lớp
của mình để tìm nhóm,
nhóm nào mà chưa đạt cái maximum là theo
cái phần hướng dẫn của cô là 15 phải
không ta?
Thì có thể nhận thêm thành viên.
Những bạn nào chưa có nhóm thì các em chủ
động nhắn tin cho các bạn nhóm trưởng là
những cái bạn được in đậm trong danh sách
để coi cái thành viên của nhóm đó còn có
cái nhu cầu nhận thêm nhóm thành viên hay
không.
Nếu được thì mình nên tự liên hệ để chọn
nhóm luôn,
còn nếu không thì lát hồi cô sẽ chọn nhóm
cho các em.
Những nhóm nào chưa đủ hành vi thì con sẽ
ưu tiên xếp vào.
Nhưng mà để tránh cái trường hợp đó thì
các em sẽ không chủ động,
thì các em liên lạc và chủ động trước đi
không được thì cũng rồi cô sẽ xử lý.
Rồi nãy giờ con mới nhìn một cái tin chat
kem với chú ý trong quá trình mà cô dạy
cô nói thì cô đang xem thì cô chỉ tập
trung vào nội dung.
Trong cái slide và trao đổi trực tiếp
thôi,
nên thêm vào mỗi một cái buổi lúc mà cô
một cái nội dung mà cô giảng xong thì cô
sẽ cho các em thời gian trao đổi thì mình.
Có thể giơ tay rồi,
cô sẽ kêu và mình ổng mới trao đổi trực
tiếp đó luôn.
Còn cái em hạn chế nhắn tin quá nhiều vào
mít tinh chat và các nội dung thông tin
không liên quan nha các em.
Cũng sẽ nó sẽ cho và cô sẽ không có giải
quyết được nữa nha.
Rồi.
Em định tên chữ, tên đặt tên gì cũng được,
ABC hoặc là đặt một cái tên tiếng Anh nào
đó cũng được để giúp để phân biệt với các
nhóm khác là được,
miễn đặt sao khác với nhóm khác là được.
Đó rồi cô sẽ.
Đánh số tự tin nhóm này sao cho các em.
Còn bạn Phạm Như Quỳnh hả?
Phạm Như Quỳnh và Nguyễn Thị Phương Dung.
Bây giờ cô sẽ tạm thời để tên của hai em
vào để cho các em tiến hành đăng ký và cô
sẽ highlight.
Nhưng mà cái danh sách hiện tại bên xe TV
là đang quản lý theo trên hệ thống yelin.
Nên em phải cần liên hệ với các thầy cô
hỗ trợ bên trung tâm để nhờ thầy cô ad
vào las. Sau này,
khi mà cô nhập điểm thì em có,
em có trong danh sách trên hệ thống thì
cô mới nhập điểm được nha.
Được không Dung Quỳnh.
Quê hương rồi bây giờ.
Nguyễn Thị Phương Dung.
Rồi con đang cập nhật tên của các bạn ở
trên đây.
Khi em cứ làm việc tiến tìm nhóm cho mình
và làm việc trước.
Tạm thời xong rồi liên hệ với trung tâm.
Tại vì sau này trước khi nhập điểm thì cô
sẽ đăng cái danh sách mới nhất trên hệ
thống.
Rồi bên anh liên hệ tương tự giống như
hai bạn trên.
Nó có nhóm nhóm nào làm xong rồi thì các
em thực hiện công việc tiếp theo nha các
em.
Tạo ra cho nhóm của mình đi.
Nhóm nào tạo ra và đạt phonder xong rồi
thì các em vào bên đây nè cô tạo bài post
rồi ha.
Các em chưa có tên nhóm khoan khoan bốt
đi chứ không nó hồi cô không phân biệt
được của nhóm nào.
Kem cứ tạo ra và cấu trúc file cái fonder
theo cái hướng dẫn của hồi nãy cô là được.
Tới 19 giờ, cô sẽ đóng nha em.
Và bên công tác quyền ha cô kiểm tra lại.
Ở đây có nhóm nào mà các em chưa có đăng
ký được không?
Cho đăng ký xong.
Rồi bây giờ cô bắt đầu.
Rồi cái này, cái mình có 117 bạn đang run,
hôm nay có bạn nào đang son đã,
son hôm nay có đi học mà hiện tại các em
chưa có nhóm không?
Những bạn này.
Dạ em chào.
Ồ.
Dạ em cho cô,
em là Nguyễn Tấn Thiện trong danh sách đó
cô. Hiện tại thì em chưa có nhóm,
em cũng có nhắn tin nhưng mà chắc là do
gấp quá mấy bạn chưa kịp trả lời á,
cho nên em nhờ cô giúp em phân một nhóm
cho em tham gia một nhóm nào.
Nhóm hiện tại có 2 nhóm này là 2 nhóm mắt
của cố ý để cuối này, nhóm 10, nhóm 11,
bạn em có quen bạn nào trong 2 nhóm này
không?
Và em em không ạ,
tại em học cải thiện cho nên cô cứ cho em
vào nhóm của bạn nào cũng được ạ.
Ok.
Dạ vâng, em cảm ơn cô.
À
Vậy đầu tiên cô sẽ xác nhận thông tin từ
nhóm và chọn nhóm chủ trước đi rồi cô
kiếm nhóm cho em sao.
Rồi Nguyễn Văn Sơn nhóm một.
Em là giám trưởng đúng không?
Nếu mình có bao nhiêu thành viên em theo
đúng đủ thành viên nào?
Em chém kéo cô ạ.
Ừ,
kem xác nhận là coi thông tin nhóm của
mình đủ không?
Giờ hiện tại là em thấy đủ.
Ừ rồi,
các em sửa tên cái fonder nhóm mà xe cho
cô á theo nhóm 1 luôn ha.
Giờ giờ.
Rồi nhóm 2 là vạn tư.
Và mình có 12 thành viên.
Đây kem kiểm tra xem nhóm của mình đủ
hành vi không em.
Ngay đủ con.
Ok,
sao thì báo cô nhóm số 3 là bạn nhóm siêu.
Gồm có 12 thành viên.
Giờ cháu em đủ rồi.
Rồi đủ rồi đúng không?
Đây là đội hình lông này là bạn này nhóm
trưởng đúng không em?
Và đúng rồi cô.
Được coi thành viên mình đúng không?
Dạ đúng 12 người.
Ok.
Ở
Nhóm này bạn mẫn.
Là nhóm trưởng đúng không em,
đủ thành viên cho em.
Có sách bạn nào luôn?
đỗ rồi.
Rồi bạn nhấn 6 này là 12 thành viên,
anh kem kiểm tra lại coi đủ hành viên
mình giống mình chưa?
Trần Thế Anh có đang nguyên.
Anh có ạ.
Ừ, đủ nhân viên đúng không em?
Mình nói em 13 bạn ạ vừa có thêm 1 bạn,
không có nhóm bạn.
Bạn nào?
An Hiệp ạ.
Của bạn Hiệp hả? Bạn Hiệp là bạn nào?
Sau đây con.
Bạn đang có tên trong danh sách không?
Em thấy bạn đấy nhắn tin với em đinh đỉnh
hiệp ạ.
Đình Hiệp, đình Hiệp đâu em?
Em có tin trong danh sách không?
Dạ có rồi cô ơi.
Ở đây đúng không? Vậy là.
Yeah.
Em có nếu mình có 12 thành viên thôi mà.
Anh 12 chứ đâu phải 13 em.
Sau 12 nè
Còn sau bạn nào hả?
Dạ, vâng ạ, còn sốt thì bạn ạ.
Các bạn có tên gì?
Nhóm 6 bạn nói tên gì trong danh sách này?
Sắp đảm bảo vợ.
Bão hả?
Trong danh sách truyền thông.
Bạn bảo đâu, bảo có trong danh sách không?
Em có tìm thấy cái tên mình trong danh
sách này không?
Bảo đây có luôn rồi mà em, bảo bảo nè.
Nếu bạn Nguyễn Văn Khánh ạ.
Trong này chưa có bạn khánh cô ạ.
Nguyễn Văn Khánh đúng không?
Là cái bạn hồi nãy mới nói chuyện với cô
đúng không em?
Khánh.
Khánh bạn, bạn khánh nào?
Bạn Nguyễn Văn Khánh ạ.
Ờ rồi cô biết rồi,
còn bạn Nguyễn Văn Khánh không mở mít tơ
cho cô phải là cái bạn hồi nãy mới dự báo
cô là em chưa có nhóm không?
Được là những trường.
Dạ em là người báo em là em là Thiện ạ
chứ không phải Khánh ạ.
À thì ok, con xin lỗi.
Hôm nay con nhìn làm cảnh.
Rồi nhóm 7 bạn nào nhóm trưởng Giang Thi
Hùng.
Dạ em của em là Hùng Vương.
Rồi vậy Giang Hùng là nhóm trưởng.
Dạ.
Danh sách hiện đại của mình là 12 bạn đủ
nguyên có thiếu bạn nào không?
Dạ đủ 12 ạ.
Ok.
Rồi nhóm số 8 và nhóm của bạn Kha là nhóm
trưởng 12, em kem bạn Kha đâu đủ rồi.
Nhạc đậu.
Dạ em đây ạ.
Rồi nhóm.
Chính là bằng phi 12 thành viên kiểm tra
đủ không em?
Dạ đủ ạ
Rồi nhóm 10 là Tuấn.
À dạ cô ơi,
nhóm số 10 fan bạn Lê Thanh Quốc giúp em
với ạ và đổi thành Chu Thị Ngọc Bích làm
trưởng nhóm giúp em luôn ạ.
Là nhóm 10 đúng không?
Dạ.
Rồi bây giờ Ngọc Chu Thị Ngọc Bích là
nhóm trưởng.
Dạ vâng.
Em nhớ bên mình có muốn thêm hành vi
không, bạn Thiện Á.
Dạ coi của em là thiện á,
cô có một bạn ở trong ma chat vừa vừa
nhận em vào nhóm 11 á cô cho em xin vào
nhóm 11 luôn.
Nếu 11 ok.
Dạ vâng, em cảm ơn cô và các bạn ạ.
Rồi vậy, bây giờ con chọn phải.
Chị nhấn của bạn 10 của bạn bích là em 7
thành viên hiện tại là 7 thành viên đầy
đủ đúng không em?
Dạ đúng rồi ạ.
Rồi vậy nhất thì một bạn nào giống trưởng
em, em bầu chọn em trưởng đi.
Tin quan.
Trần Minh Quang là những trường đúng
không em?
Chúng mình hiện tại có 6 thành viên đúng
không? Kiểu kiểm tra có đủ không em?
Một có nhập điểm theo vai này đó nha.
Về.
Ok.
Ở đây có bạn nào trong danh sách này đi
học?
Mà chưa có nhóm không?
Thắng Khanh đạt tuyến vinh và dương.
Dạ, xin chào cô,
em tên là Nguyễn Văn Trương,
cô em chưa có nhóm.
Nguyễn Văn Nghiệp.
Cái văn chương.
Ở đây em có chồng không có tên sách.
Dạ.
Ở cô cho trương vào nhóm em luôn.
Em nhắn tin vô.
Nhóm 11 cô.
Nếu 11 không đi.
Chương đâu chương.
Gửi cho cô mà số nhân viên của em nhập
cho cô nhập thông tin của em.
Dạ, thưa cô, em gửi rồi hả cô?
Ừ.
Nhớ được các bạn mà màu đỏ thì nhớ liên
hệ trung tâm nhờ trung tâm cập nhật cho
mình nha các em.
Chứ mình không có tên trên hệ thống rồi
mới không có nhập điểm được.
Rồi bạn chương này là nhóm 11 luôn.
Rồi có bạn nào.
Sưng vào nữa không các em?
Chị giống như một hiện tại là 7 thành
viên ha.
Còn bạn nào nữa không?
Rồi nếu mà các nhóm đủ hết rồi thì bây
giờ các mỗi nhóm đại diện một bạn đăng ký
bò cao cho nhóm mình.
Để tạo cái ride sau đó kem mau ra nha và
kem sau này khi mà làm việc là các em sử
dụng email cá nhân của các em để các em
nộp bài và sửa bài cho đó để cô nhìn thấy
được tiến trình lịch sử của các bạn tương
tác và làm việc trên RRI.
Của mình luôn ha.
Và nhóm nào mà nằm xong thì các em.
Relay cho cái bài post này cho cô.
Cô tạo phải bó rồi nè.
Đại diện nhóm trưởng ghi thông tin nhóm
và dán lên vô,
cô sẽ kiểm tra coi nhóm của mình tạo cái
firide theo đúng hướng dẫn chưa và tạo
theo cái hướng dẫn này nha các em.
Nếu ta thấy hướng dẫn này,
nhóm nào xong thì cô sẽ tạo,
cô sẽ cho em khoảng 15 phút để tạo ha.
Nếu nào tạo xong thì kem cứ đây rồi cô
kiểm tra.
Ngọc bích relay cho đúng mày boss em.
Rồi lây vô cái bài post cập nhật ra nhóm.
Xóa cái bài bóp của em đi hết.
Nếu 11 chủ xe quyền cho cô nhé.
Nếu xe quyền qua cái email này nha em.
Trong cái mail, cái mail trong đốc đó cô.
Em xem mail này đúng không?
Đúng rồi, đúng rồi.
Em treo Quyền Editor.
Sao cô,
đây là cô thấy cô không có quyền mà.
Mới xe đó,
em hồi nãy em không có quyền hồi nãy là
nó đâu có chuyển xe buýt mi.
Dạ.
Ừ, các thành viên khác của Editor luôn em.
Các bạn phải dùng email cá nhân của các
bạn để làm việc mà.
Em để đi vô để em set là sao?
Mọi người có quyền view còn lại là Editor
nhé.
Xét lại đi em.
Nhóm 5
Em xét quyền cho các con đơn của mình hả?
Khoáng rồi hả?
Cô phải có quyền On tương đương quyền
Onner của các em nha.
Những năm đầu.
M.
chỉnh con.
Ừ.
Chỉnh lại xong rồi mở quyền viewer cho
các bạn.
2 lấy.
Nhóm nằm sẽ xong chưa em?
Còn nhóm 1, nhóm 6 và nhóm 7.
Kem tới đâu rồi.
năm có.
Em xong rồi đếm.
Nhóm nằm sửa xong rồi đúng không?
Rồi còn giống 6 7.
Với 1.
Anh em đến 7 sau,
bây giờ em lập vô cái xe của team của.
Play vô đây em.
Relay bên đây em.
Dạ.
Rồi lây vô bài post này.
Ừ.
Nhóm nào xong rồi ra dưới đó thì cô kiểm
tra ha.
Rồi nhóm 5 sao các em là đẩy lên right
của cô ta.
Nhóm 5
Dạ em nghe con.
Là em vẫn để bên bên giống em chỉ là xe
cái quyền.
Để cái quyền editor cho mọi người giống
như bình thường á,
cái cô thấy cái giống như em đang khoác
cái quyền á.
Chứ em treo qua cô là cô không có quản lý
riêng cho từng nhóm đâu.
Kem pha tẩy tự lên nhóm trên right của
mình.
Do giá trị cô nãy em cũng là cô nói là
chuyển quyền sở hữu nên là em mới chuyển.
Để.
Không có chuyện,
chỉ ý cô nói là để cái quyền anitor mà cô
vẫn có thể quyền chỉnh các quyền viewer
khác.
Hồi nãy là cái fonder của em bị khóa lại.
Hồi nãy em chuyển như thế nào,
ta có dùng cái chức năng này của nó,
em chuyển nó đâu?
Chờ cô vô chỗ chia sẻ xong rồi.
Chia sẻ chia sẻ.
C tin
Cô tìm giúp em mẫn phạm.de.
Lại mạng đúng không?
Ở trang phòng only sit cho em ha.
Rồi cho huyền vai đi.
Được dương mẫn.
Tôi xe quyền rồi đó, em đã xếp đi.
Gi.
Em thấy em vẫn chưa có nhận được cái việc
quét nó chuyển sở hữu của con.
Đúng năm
Cô thấy nó ghi Benin On mà.
Cô chuyển rồi,
và cô lích lại là cô cancel.
Em refresh lại thử coi.
Còn nhóm nhóm này là nhóm gì,
nhóm xét là nhóm gì?
Nhấn mạnh nhóm 7 đó hả,
hỏi nhóm 6 năm nay em là nhóm 6 á hả?
Em xóa khóa gì đây vậy ta?
Dạng nhóm 5 em sẽ access rồi.
Ok đấy, cô re khoét.
Rồi thành xe buýt mi rồi.
Ok
Nếu mà em chuyển qua đó rồi,
ở đây cô mua chắc thông minh hưởng thôi
nhỉ.
Ok, không sao.
Ủa sao lý miệng Asset nếu mà.
Nhóm xét.
Xe quyền cho cô em điểm 6 á.
Chưa được sửa tên nhóm nữa.
Bằng tay.
Ừ.
Dạ để em sướng không?
Rồi nhóm này em bị xóa rồi nhóm 7.
Dạ, còn để em check lại tại vì nó đang bị.
Rồi nhóm 6 sữa xong chưa?
Dạ xong rồi cô.
Rồi nhấn sáo xong.
Rồi các em nhớ chết bên đây á,
mốt mà cô thu bài để cô chấm điểm là cô
sẽ chấm từ cái ship này nha.
Nên các em kiểm tra tên của mình phải còn
tồn tại nha.
Được rồi cô chấm bài có nhiều nhóm các em
không kiểm tra bị sao.
Mai và các em phải nhớ chú ý là mình hoạt
động trong một dự án, khi mà làm.
Mọi dự án nó sẽ có các role riêng giống
như các room và cô hướng dẫn các em á và
các em phải tuân thủ nó để mình mới hợp
tác được.
Các cái quy định,
thí dụ người ta đặt quy định phân tích,
thiết kế về cái quy định,
cái hình vẽ để hiểu ý nghĩa chung.
Thì em phải đi theo cái ru đó,
em vẽ thì người ta mới hiểu cái đoạn đó
là dành cho aster hay là cái phân xanh đó
phải làm như thế nào.
Còn em tự không theo tuân thủ theo quy
định mà em tự chế á.
Thì cái đó là người ta sẽ không hiểu và
người ta sẽ không thực hiện được ha giống
như là rồi.
Cô thu bài cũng sẽ có những trường hợp
các em không làm thì hướng dẫn là các em
để lộn rất là lộn xộn các em trong quá
trình làm các em có thể tạo ra nhiều vai.
Nhưng mà khi mà tạo cô cho em thời hạn
sữa và chỉnh sau khi góp ý.
Và nếu mà đã ra cái chỉnh rồi thì hãy tạo
thành phiên bản cuối cùng,
còn các bạn phiên bản kia hãy tạo một
fonder riêng.
Nếu như là các phương với Overson vậy đó,
và mình dọn dẹp cái thư mục cho mình một
cái sạch sẽ để cô vô cô biết cái nào là
chính của kem.
Có trường hợp các nhóm là các em để vô.
Các em đặt tên y chang nhau luôn hoặc là
tên nó mang chất gợi nhớ như cũng là đồ
án môn học, đồ án môn học final,
đồ án môn học chữ FN.
Giống như tự viết tắt vậy,
sau đó cuối cùng cô phải dựa trên cái
ngày cuối cùng mà cô quyết định là cô
chọn cái ngày mà chỉnh sửa cuối cùng cái
file nào cũng nhất á.
Thì là cái fan mà là cái fan mới nhất chứ
cái fan mà được sửa mới nhất gần nhất
thôi là còn lấy cái fan đó cô chấm thôi.
Thì nếu cô kem khi mình làm mình cố ý
tránh những trường hợp đó nha,
nhóm nào mà cô kiếm hoài không ra sản
phẩm thì mình không có sản phẩm cho cô
chấm nha.
Rồi.
Còn nhóm 7 khôi phục được chưa các em.
Nhưng mà chắc bị số tài khoản rồi đó,
các em tạo tài khoản.
Và xong rồi thì các em relay lại để cô
biết cô nắm thông tin ha.
Những 6 là xong.
Nhớ rồi like nha,
từ like thì nó mới tạo notif mới.
Rồi các em tự kiểm tra trong danh sách
của mình có đúng không hả?
Nhóm nào sai thì nhóm trưởng mở mít báo
hoặc là đại chuyển nhóm mã mít báo cũng
được.
Ở nhóm với một em bổ sung thêm Nguyễn Văn
Khánh có không có comment.
Văn khánh thì bạn nó có trong danh sách
nhóm chưa em, danh sách lớp chưa?
Có rồi.
Nguyễn Hoàng Khánh Nguyễn Hoàng Khánh
đúng.
Bạn anh em 6 cô ơi.
Đang ở nhóm 6 cô.
Đánh con trái cho nhầm 6.
Rồi bây giờ các em vô nhóm máy,
kem là nhóm máy.
Bạn Khánh qua năm 11 rồi.
Nếu 11 đúng
Dạ, cô ơi,
mình tạo thêm thư mục vào trong cái vibe
đó cũng được mà đúng không cô?
Về nhóm 11 là tắm.
Đúng rồi,
sau này các bài tập của em tạo đó,
hồi cô hướng dẫn tạo bài tập đầu tiên cho
các em và các em chỉ cần nộp đường link
thôi.
Các em đã share quyền cho cô cái fonder
lớn nhất rồi thì các phương do sao các em
chỉ cần tạo rồi share link được cô vô
được.
Cô không cần là không cần phải sẽ quyền
lợi.
tâm.
Rồi đó là nhóm 11 cô cập nhật rồi đó,
các em kiểm tra lại đi ha.
Ở Vành Khánh nó cô chứ không phải là
hoàng.
Văn Khánh, Nguyễn Văn Khánh.
Văn Khánh,
Văn Khánh đâu có trong đây đâu em?
Để kem coi lại nè.
Ủa cô ơi,
em có mà cô em có trong nhóm lớp nè.
Danh sách lớp á.
Dạ em là bạn được vô sau trong nhóm được
ờ vừa trường được thêm vào nhóm.
Danh sách lớp, danh sách lớp,
danh sách lớp nè,
em thấy danh sách lớp luôn.
Em hiểu không?
Các em vô và các em phải biết là cô hồi
nãy cô mới nói đầu giờ đó cái em coi mình
có trong danh sách lớp hay không,
hổng có thì các em sẽ nhập cô đưa thông
tin cô sẽ nhập giống như các bạn màu đỏ.
Cô bổ sung tay,
nhưng mà các em vẫn phải liên hệ với các
thầy cô trung tâm bên.
Ngay từ đây nhờ các thầy cô áp vào lớp
này thì khi đó cô lúc mà nhập điểm cô đau
Dạ rồi dẹp để em đăng nhập.
xuống hiểu không cô nhập điểm bây giờ
mình là quản lý trên hệ thống CID và cô
mới đó.
Bây giờ cây không có trong danh sách này
thì một đâu có chọn để nhập điểm.
Thực sự ngày cứ.
Đây là mình chỉ là nhập tạm thời thôi.
Hiện tại là mình là nhập tạm thời đó,
em đưa cho cô mã số sinh viên đi.
Dạ, em có nhắn.
Tại vì biết tin chắc.
Bên nick WeChat đúng luôn.
Dạ em có chán nhắn trong full chat với cô.
Rồi.
Kiểu nhạc cô cô dạ.
Nguyễn Văn Khánh, cô thấy rồi.
Nhớ nhưng mà mình vẫn nhớ liên hệ với cô,
thầy cô bên trung tâm nhờ cập nhật trên
hệ thống nha.
Ừ.
À dạ vậy để em nhờ bên trung tâm ạ.
Ừ, tại đây con đang nhập tạm thôi.
Tới lúc mà cô nhập điểm chấm thì gần cuối
cô sẽ lên hệ thống của đo danh sách mới
nhất và cô sẽ chỉnh sửa cái thang cái
danh sách mới nhất.
Tại vì danh sách của mình cập nhật theo
danh sách mới nhất để mình nhập điểm.
Rồi bây giờ bạn Nguyễn Văn Khánh là những.
Rồi nhớ 118 thành viên hả anh em coi lại
danh sách của mình nha em.
Dạ đúng rồi ạ.
Các bạn nào nhắc lại nha,
các bạn màu đỏ là các bạn không có tên
trong danh sách gốc.
Có nghĩa là cái danh sách đó là cô được
down thì hệ thống xuống gửi qua đó.
Và bây giờ là đang tạm thời nhập tay để
các em lập nhóm.
Và bây giờ các em muốn có sao này kem có
điểm trên hệ thống gặp cô đặc điểm của
trên hệ thống cho điểm của em được thì
kem phải có lên danh sách chính thức của
lớp nên các em phải liên hệ với các nhân,
các thầy cô bên trung tâm CTV nhờ cập
nhật của mình vô danh sách lớp này.
Thì lúc mà cô chấm điểm cái danh sách
cuối kỳ thì cô đăng cái danh sách mới
nhất về có tên em.
Trong đó thì cô mới nhập điểm về hệ thống
được,
còn không là mình không có nhập điểm trên
hệ thống được nha cái em.
Các bạn màu đỏ.
Nhật qua rồi.
Sao em?
Em có xe link brank mà giờ hiện tại em
chỉ có tron được có 10 thành viên là còn
2 thành viên nữa chưa vào được thì.
Những cái ảnh em gửi trên WeChat.
Em share cho cô chưa yêu cho cô coi.
Nhạc xe cho cô rồi nhóm 2 à.
Em real like với bài post rồi đúng không?
Ồ,
nhóm 2 nhóm 2 là kem đưa tin rồi mà đúng
không?
Dạ đúng rồi, em gửi cho cô rồi,
nhưng mà hiện tại chị vô được có một
thành viên rồi còn thiếu 2 thành viên nữa.
Các em có tạo ra mới không?
Dạ, cái mail này mới tạo.
Bia này mới tạo.
Vâng.
Tại em có nhóm 3 trước rồi,
cái em tạo theo nhóm.
Em mới em tạo rồi như em,
lý nghịch này em thấy.
Em lý mịt mà em đang.
Cái giới hạn quyền access của Funder.
Ừ.
Có để chạm để em xem lại à.
Ừ,
cái này kem tạo phân đôi bình thường thôi,
các bạn giống khác cái tạo fonder bình
thường. Thí dụ ở đây các em tạo á,
cô cũng không biết sao các em tạo ra cái
này nè. Tâm lý bị accept.
Kem setting trên hệ thống.
Giờ hết rồi nè.
Do hết rồi nè,
hồi nãy là cái dấu giới hạn có thể là do
em hoặc là do cái fonder mình,
cái ra mình mới tạo Google ra giới hạn,
Google ra mấy cái email mới tạo là dễ bị
giới hạn ban đầu bây giờ hết rồi nè.
Em hát là thử luôn.
Dạ,.
Để mệt lại rồi, còn gì em cập nhật lại,
em cảm ơn ạ.
Ok.
Rồi tao cập nhật chính sách rồi.
Rồi mình bắt đầu học đi kêu.
Buổi đầu tiên hôm nay mình sẽ làm quen
với các khái niệm cơ bản trong cái môn
học của mình.
Rồi.
Cà đẹp sai chú Ngọc Á, em có thể.
Coi trên drive của mình hả?
Thì trong phần này mình sẽ học về tổng
quan,
biết về các thành phần công nghệ thông
tin trong một tổ chức và cái bối cảnh ứng
dụng của nó. Gồm có 3 phần chính ha.
Thứ nhất,
đầu tiên mình sẽ tìm hiểu về vai trò của
công nghệ thông tin trong tổ chức.
À,
các em sẽ đứng dưới góc độ xem đó là cái
vì sao nó được gọi là xương sống và đòn
bẩy chiến lược và cơ chế quản trị rủi ro.
Thì các em sẽ phải hình dung á.
Công nghệ thông tin của mình trong cái
giai đoạn hiện tại bây giờ mình tiếp xúc
nhiều rồi trong giai đau bùng nổ thông
tin thì mình cái phần này chắc không cần
phải nói nhiều.
Hầu như tất cả các cái doanh nghiệp,
đơn vị.
Hoặc là cá nhân các em hoạt động làm việc
đều phải thông qua cái máy tính và các
cái ứng dụng trong lĩnh vực công nghệ
thông tin của mình.
Và đối với cái góc độ của một cái đơn vị
á thì nó là được xem.
Như là một cái xương sống vận hành hầu
như một cái công ty doanh nghiệp hiện tại,
phần lớn họ sẽ đều có thể quản lý và
trong cái quy trình,
các em sẽ hình dung mình đi làm rồi thì
các em sẽ biết á là trong một công ty nó
sẽ có nhiều bộ phận phải không?
Một bộ phận nó sẽ có nhiều quy trình làm
việc.
Khác nhau và cái đó là phải là nhiệm vụ
mà thường trong hợp đồng lao động của
mình nó sẽ ghi là các em phải có bắt đầu
làm cái nhiệm vụ gì để đem lại lợi ích
cho doanh nghiệp thì đối với các hoạt
động nghiệp vụ trong cái quy trình nghiệp
vụ đó xem như nó là vai trò và bình
thường.
Khi mà trong thời đại hiện tại,
thì các cái tất cả những cái nhiệm vụ đó
của các em đều có được,
có thể được thực hiện và các em thông qua
cái ứng dụng công nghệ thông tin để các
em triển khai cái quy trình.
Làm việc đó một cách tốt nhất.
Hầu như là không có tiền nhiều.
Mình đều sẽ có tiếp xúc qua và sử dụng nó
thì trong một cái công ty á nó sẽ có một
cái một số cái quy trình nghiệp vụ lỗi ở
đây thường thường là mỗi cái công ty ở
các lĩnh vực khác nhau thì nó sẽ.
Có cái quy trình thực hiện khác nhau,
ví dụ giống như trường đại học hay bệnh
viện thì các em sẽ thấy một cái là bên
giáo dục một cái là bên y tế và mỗi bên
đều sẽ có những cái quy trình chuyên biệt
riêng giống như bên giáo dục.
Trong trường đại học thì có quy trình học
tập và làm việc và giảng dạy, nghiên cứu.
Thí dụ bên trường của mình,
công nghệ thông tin thì có 2 nhiệm vụ
chính,
đó là nhiệm vụ giảng dạy và nghiên cứu.
Các cái công nghệ mới và ứng dụng vào
trong quá trình giảng dạy của mình đòi
hỏi bên ngành công nghệ thông tin hiện
tại là như vậy,
các ngành khác thì xuống cũng đi đang đi
theo cái nhiệm vụ như thế.
Nhưng mà về chi tiết của từng ngành thì
cô không rõ thì cô không về chuyên ngành
bên đó,
nhưng mà đối với các thành viên trong
trường đại học công nghệ thông tin á,
trong hai trong đại học quốc gia nói
chung thì nó sẽ đều các trường thành viên,
đều có cái nhiệm vụ giống như nhau hết là
sẽ đòi hỏi, nghiên cứu trí.
Sâu hơn về cái chuyên ngành của mình đưa
ra cái công bố khoa học mới và ứng dụng
nó vô các cái quá trình giảng dạy và nếu
được thì khuyến khích hợp tác với các cái
công ty hoặc là các cái quỹ.
Để mình cố gắng và hiện thực hóa nó lên
ha hiện được hóa nó lên hoặc làm có cái
chương trình demo có thể là một bạn demo
sử dụng thử thì đó là các cái.
Thì cái hoạt động nghiệp vụ riêng của bên
giáo dục.
Còn nếu như bệnh viện thì cái hoạt động
chính để tạo ra nguồn thu,
nó lại là hoạt động khám chữa bệnh.
Giống như là các hoạt động khám chữa bệnh
giữa bệnh nhân,
bác sĩ và các cái xét nghiệm y khoa.
Thì đó là các cái hoạt động chuyên biệt
riêng,
nhưng mà nó sẽ có những cái nghiệp vụ mà
cả bệnh viện hay là cả trường đại học đều
sẽ phải có thì thường những cái nghiệp vụ
quan trọng đó người ta gọi là các cái
nghiệp vụ lỗi.
Giống như là bị quản lý các cái nhân sự
kế toán.
À, vậy,
các cái hoạt động Office hoặc là các cái
quy trình cần được.
Ứng dụng cười thông tin được số hóa nó
lên thì hầu như phần lớn các cái công ty,
đơn vị, doanh nghiệp đều sẽ có.
Và cái này em sẽ thấy nó sẽ được lặp lại
rất là nhiều.
Cái em muốn biết cái sự giống nhau của nó
khi về các cái nghiệp vụ loại.
Khi mà mình học tới ngành môn cơ sở dữ
liệu,
môn cơ sở dữ liệu là tạo ra nền tảng để
cho các em học các cái hệ thống web và
ứng dụng di động.
Thì thực chất bản thân của cơ sở dữ liệu
là các em xây dựng các cái.
Cơ sở dữ liệu để lưu các thông tin quan
trọng trong cái quy trình hoạt động ở các
công ty.
Thí dụ thường thường các đề thi giống như
các đề thi hồi năm mấy năm trước cô cho
tham gia cho thì tìm hiểu,
xây dựng cơ sở dữ liệu cho.
Quản lý mua bán vé cho sân bay chẳng hạn.
Còn không là quản lý bán hàng,
mua hàng tại hoặc là quản lý về sản xuất
ở tại một cái công ty,
ví dụ mình lập giả lập là Vinamilk,
về cái quy trình sản xuất ở Vinamilk
chẳng hạn.
Mình chọn một cái đơn vị và các em tìm
hiểu về nó và cho các sinh viên tập làm
xây dựng cơ sở dữ liệu rồi làm thành một
bài thi thì khi mà mình làm qua nhiều bài
rồi thì các em sẽ thấy phần lớn rất nhiều
vụ nó cũng quan đi quan lại về các nghiệp
vụ chính đó thôi.
Tuy nhiên,
nó sẽ có những nghiệp vụ chuyên biệt và
cái yêu cầu riêng.
Nhưng về phần lớn thì nó sẽ vẫn có những
cái nghiệp vụ cốt lõi thì nó sẽ có cái
thông qua cái hệ thống cốt lõi đó và các
hạ tầng kỹ thuật hiện tại thì mình sẽ
thấy là ngày xưa thì chỉ hoặc làm việc
trên máy tính.
Nhưng mà bây giờ là phải có mạng các cái
rất nhiều công nghệ nền tảng phải dựa
trên kết nối mạng để phát triển.
Giống như các công nghệ về cloud hoặc là
công nghệ nền tảng blockchain.
Hay là các cái nền tảng bên AIation hiện
tại nó cũng kết hợp khá là nhiều.
Bây giờ các cái,
nếu mà các em tìm hiểu kỹ thì các ngành
công các cái từ khóa trong ngành công
nghệ thông tin của mình cái.
Giới hạn về các cái loại lĩnh vực đó
không có quá rõ ràng và thường nó giao
thoa kết hợp với nhau để cùng vận hành ha.
Và mình đương nhiên là mình sẽ phải đầu
tư các hạ tầng kỹ thuật rất là nhiều
thiết bị đi theo và mình do có nhiều
thông tin quan trọng.
Ở trong nghiệp vụ và nó được chia sẻ với
nhau thông qua hệ thống mạng,
và để cho dễ sử dụng và vận hành trong
môi trường hiện tại nên nó sẽ dẫn đến một
vấn đề.
Hot đi theo á là làm sao mình bảo vệ
thông tin nó một cách đảm bảo quyền riêng
tư,
nè đảm bảo bảo mật thông tin không bị
chỉnh sửa.
Ví dụ,
giống như các thông tin điểm sinh viên
không được bị tự động chỉnh sửa,
tấn công tự động chỉnh sửa thì cái hệ
thống thông tin đó mất an toàn,
không bảo mật và nó không có đủ uy tín để
được vận hành.
Nên người ta sẽ có các thành phần chuyên
về các lĩnh vực này.
Ha và mình phải đảm bảo cái dữ liệu của
mình luôn sẵn sàng hiệu năng và liên tục.
Thì cái một công nghệ,
một cái ứng dụng công nghệ,
một cái hệ thống mà người ta đầu tư cơ sở
hạ tầng công nghệ thông tin tốt,
nó không phải chỉ dùng để vận hành tốt mà
nó còn giúp trong cái quá trình của mình
vận hành.
Không bị lỗi nè,
không bị gián đoạn và cái không tốn quá
nhiều chi phí.
Thì và nó nếu mà cái hạ tầng này kem đầu
tư tốt thì nó sẽ là xương sống cho quá
toàn quá trình vận hành của công ty.
Còn đối với và khi mà trong cái lĩnh vực
hiện tại mình sẽ thấy là.
Trước đây thường thường cái dự án dụng
web của mình hoặc ứng dụng thiết bị di
động của mình á.
Nó hay được xây dựng dựa trên cơ sở dữ
liệu và chủ yếu dùng để quản lý cái gì đó
thôi.
Thí dụ giống như trong trường của mình là.
Trường đại học thì là quản lý sinh viên,
quản lý giảng viên,
quản lý hoạt động học tập, quản lý điểm,
quản lý nhân sự.
Trọng Minh ngoài thì thường quản lý bán
hàng, quản lý tài chính, vân vân,
nó có thể có nhiều cái quản lý khác nhau
và thường là mình **** cái công ty,
doanh nghiệp đó người ta trong quy trình
của người ta,
người ta muốn quản lý cái gì thì mình sẽ
thường xây dựng một cái hệ thống quản lý
cho họ.
Và nó sẽ đi đôi đương nhiên là song song
rồi,
phải xây dựng cơ sở dữ liệu rồi xây dựng
hệ thống quét và ứng dụng di động để cho
người ta sử dụng cho các cái quản lý cơ
bản đó.
Nhưng mà trong cái thời đại hiện tại thì
mình kem sẽ thấy là có rất là nhiều công
nghệ mới.
Và người ta **** muốn không chỉ dừng ở
quản lý mà người **** muốn hỗ trợ nhằm
tham gia tạo ra các giá trị mới.
Và nếu mà mình vận dụng tốt thì nó có thể
là chiến lược phát triển mạnh hơn với các
hệ thống khác.
Như là các em mình hiểu về cái thông tin
dựa trên dữ liệu để mình hỗ trợ ra quyết
định tốt hơn, tự động báo tốt hơn,
rồi ứng dụng AI để mình nâng cao trải
nghiệm của người dùng.
Quy dân và cái ứng dụng AI ở đây nó luôn,
cái ứng dụng AI để nâng cao trải nghiệm
khách hàng.
Thì nó phải là các ứng dụng được tạo bên.
Dựa trên dữ liệu và nó không phải thuần
dựa trên quản lý dữ liệu ở trong đây khi
mà cô dạy nhiều hệ sinh viên khác nhau
thì có một số bạn các em không đi sâu,
các em bắt đầu từ ngành khác, các em qua.
Ngành này á thì cái mà cái tôi thấy các
em hay sai nhiều nhất á là các em không
phân biệt được thế nào là ứng dụng AI vào
một cái hệ thống thông tin quản lý bình
thường.
Khi mà người ta nói ứng dụng với ai là
người ta phải khai thác thông tin dữ liệu,
khai thác tri thức từ dữ liệu thì các em
sẽ hiểu là cái tri thức đó nó không có
sẵn trong cơ sở dữ liệu để mình lấy ra
mình coi.
Cái gì giống như em có hệ thống thông tin
quản lý học tập của học tập của sinh viên
đi em biết muốn quyết điểm của em bao
nhiêu và em cái điểm của em nó được lưu
trong cơ sở dữ liệu và mình lấy lên mình
xem.
Hoặc là bây giờ mình có cái phân loại là
dựa trên điểm đó phân loại sinh viên là
loại giỏi khá là xuất sắc.
Bây giờ mình có điểm rồi thì bây giờ nó
sẽ tự động phân loại.
Dựa trên cái điểm cố định được lưu trong
cơ sở dữ liệu thì cái cóp mà kiểu tự động
phân loại đó,
nó chỉ là cái ứng dụng quản lý bình
thường thôi chứ các em.
Có các bạn cứ nghe tự động phân loại là
cứ hiểu lại ai thì nó không phải ai nha
các em ai là nó khai thác thông tin từ
tri thức mà cái.
Cái mà cái tri thức mà nó xuất ra cho em
coi á nó không có sẵn trong cái cơ sở dữ
liệu đang có mà nó phải học thông tin từ
một lượng lớn dữ liệu rất là lớn và các
công cụ học phải nghe khá là nhiều đó.
Nó chính là celanin.
Mà Deep Lenin là một phần của màu Cinanin
hoặc là trang Fallanin gì đó chỉ là con
của màu Cinanin thôi mà Cinanin các em có
thể hiểu nó là một cái lĩnh vực rất lớn
và.
Nó bảo hơn mấy cái kia luôn á thì cái
người ta sử dụng công cụ của Sinanin để
khai thác thông tin từ dữ liệu và show
lên cho mình xem vào mỗi cá nhân khác
nhau thì sẽ thấy một cái thông tin khác
nhau.
Tại vì cái thông tin dữ liệu khai thác từ
mỗi đối tượng nó khác nhau.
Cái mà kem thấy nhiều nhất,
ứng dụng của kem coi nhiều nhất chính là
cái hệ thống khuyến nghị á trên mấy cái
sàn thương mại điện tử.
Mỗi bạn lên thì các em sẽ thấy mỗi bạn sẽ
có một cái danh sách khuyến nghị sản phẩm
mua hàng khác nhau.
Tại vì nó học từ trải nghiệm mua hàng và
lịch sử mua hàng. Thói quen luôn.
Và thông tin cá nhân của em để nó gợi ý.
Và để làm điều đó là phải học lượng lớn,
rất là nhiều thông tin rồi training cái
này bạn này đi sau thì mình sẽ làm cái đó
hiểu về cái đó nhiều hơn á training khai
thác rồi dự đoán.
Và với mỗi người ở mỗi thời điểm khác
nhau,
nó sẽ xuất ra một cái danh sách khác nhau,
có nghĩa là khi cái.
Yêu cầu em thay đổi,
em search em tìm kiếm dữ liệu kỹ thuật số
của em thay đổi á thì em sẽ thấy cái danh
sách đó nó thay đổi theo chứ nó không cố
định.
Và cái thông tin tri thức mà người ta
khai thác để xô lên cho em coi như vậy
thì đương nhiên cái lượng hạ tầng bên
dưới nó sẽ phải tốn hạ tầng và tốn cái
chi phí.
Vận hành rất là nhiều nên chi phí của một
cái ứng dụng AI thường nó lớn ha và nó
nhờ cái trải nghiệm cá nhân hóa đó,
nó mới gọi là nâng cao trải nghiệm khách
hàng của mình hay là người dùng.
Nói chung.
Cái ứng dụng kiểu đó tao mới gọi là ứng
dụng.
Chứ cái dữ liệu mà nào mà em có sẵn ra
trong Elu trong cơ sở dữ liệu rồi em lấy
lên em show cho người dùng coi hoặc là em
áp dụng các kỹ thuật có lập trình cơ bản
để em nghĩ đoán đó thì nó không phải ứng
dụng với ai.
Rồi mở rộng hệ sinh thái khác nhau.
Ngoài ra thì ở đây nó phải có cơ chế quản
trị rủi ro đúng không?
Một cái hệ thống ứng dụng công nghệ thông
tin nó xịn, nó có dữ liệu quan trọng,
có rất nhiều dữ liệu cá nhân quan trọng
của mình thì nó phải an toàn.
Nó không được bị rối thông tin và đảm bảo
quyền truyền riêng tư của người dùng.
Thì khi nó đạt đủ hết 3 yếu tố này thì
tao mới gọi là một cái mới đạt đủ cái vai
trò của công nghệ thông tin.
Nói chung á nghiệp.
Rồi tới đây các em có chỗ này không rõ
không?
Rồi nếu mà ổng là mình đi tiếp phần thứ 2
thì đầu tiên mình nó phải có đạt đủ,
đạt hết những cái vai trò đó thì bây giờ
nó sẽ gồm những cái thành phần nào.
Thì thực sự thì công nghệ thông tin nó
phức tạp và nó lớn nên nó sẽ có cái hạ
tầng của nó.
Nó sẽ có nhiều cách phân loại khác nhau ở
dưới nhiều góc nhìn khác nhau,
ví dụ giống như một cái từ hệ thống thông
tin quản lý thôi, đứng ở nhiều góc.
Cái nhìn khác nhau thì người ta sẽ đặt
nhiều cái tên khác nhau.
Có những cái thì người ta đặt theo tên
công ty,
có những cái người ta đặt theo cái phạm
vi hoạt động giống như là quản lý nhân sự,
quản lý tài chính vậy đó có một số thì họ
đặt theo cái.
Chức năng,
chức năng nổi bật của nó giống như là hệ
thống quản lý nhân sự thông minh.
Cho nên cái này nó do góc nhìn khác nhau
thôi. Nên trong cái phần lớn về hạ tầng.
Được công nhận nhiều thì người ta sẽ khi
nói về công nghệ thông tin thì nó sẽ gồm
có 5 lớp hạ tầng chính và mình sẽ đi theo
5 lớp năng lực này.
Theo cái trong cái môn của mình luôn ha,
mình phân loại thống nhất theo cái này để
cho dễ.
Tại vì khi các em đặt tài liệu thì có thể
là sau này thời gian một vài thời gian
tới cô đọc mà cô thấy nó có cách phân
loại hay hơn và sát với cái đặc điểm mà
cái thời điểm hiện tại thì cái này nó có
thể thay đổi.
Nhưng mà trong cái chương trình của mình
thì mình sẽ thống nhất theo cái tài liệu
phân loại theo năm lớp,
năng lực cơ bản thường có ở một công ty
cơ quan này.
Ha là các lớp năng lực về hạ tầng tính
toán, kết nối rồi nền tảng vận hành,
rồi cái lớp.
Quyền lực danh tính bảo mật và lớp nền
tảng ứng dụng tích hợp và lớp nền tảng dữ
liệu thì các em sẽ hiểu là mấy cái hạ
tầng này nó phải đầy đủ tất cả các thành
phần này.
Thường đầy đủ các lớp năng lực này,
nó mới hoạt động tốt.
Và cái dữ liệu là cái.
Lớp nền tảng đi thực chất dù ở giai đoạn
trước đây chưa ai chưa có nhiều,
chỉ là lớp quản lý thì dữ liệu vẫn là nền
tảng quan trọng nhất.
Nếu bạn nào mà làm vào công ty.
Các em có tiếp xúc với dự án công nghệ
thông tin rồi thì các em sẽ biết là cái
bộ phận quản lý dữ liệu và cái bộ phận
quản lý bảo mật nhất.
Đôi khi team IT không có quyền truy cập
vào dữ liệu luôn. Thấy dữ liệu là.
Có giá trị nên mới có coi dữ liệu là vàng,
ví dụ em tưởng tượng dữ liệu đó là thông
tin điểm,
điểm sinh viên hay là thông tin số tài
khoản ngân hàng của các em?
Hoặc là thông tin số dư của em nếu mà một
cái đối tượng có thể tấn công vào nhóm
ngân hàng và sửa thông tin số dư của em
thì các em sẽ thấy nó sẽ là gây ra hậu
quả thực tế rất là nhiều.
À, ngoài ra,
người ta có thể khai thác cá nhân của
mình để làm rất nhiều việc khác nhau,
các cái vấn đề về lừa đảo hiện tại cũng
là một phần hậu quả của cái việc rò rỉ
thông tin cá nhân ấy.
Không năm bao thì riêng tư của người dùng
là khi người ta thu thập thông tin cá
nhân của mình rồi người ta sử dụng.
Người ta có thể sử dụng nó làm cho nhiều
mục đích khác nhau.
Mình không kiểm soát được.
Cái đây là hiện tại,
cái vấn đề an ninh mạng mà người ta đang
đặt và cố gắng kiểm soát nó.
Nên các em cũng có thể hiểu là trong một
cái dự án thực chất,
cái nền tảng dữ liệu và cái nền tảng quan
trọng nhất.
Và cái ứng dụng media hiện tại của mình á
thực chất cũng là lấy dữ liệu thêm dữ
liệu càng nhiều.
Thì cái công an nó có khả năng nó càng
thông minh hơn.
Nên đối với bất kỳ một hạ tầng công nghệ
thông tin nào thì cái lớp này là cái lớp
quan trọng nhất,
bắt buộc phải có ha không chỉ dùng để
quản lý mà còn dùng để hệ thác thông tin
luôn,
sau đó là mình đương nhiên là sau đó mình
phải có các nền tảng ứng dụng tích hợp
với nhau để mình sử dụng.
Và mình phải cần nó bảo mật,
đảm bảo các bảo mật phải có mã hóa dữ
liệu, phân loại dữ liệu,
phân quyền dữ liệu cho nó tốt rồi mình sẽ
phải có cơ chế vận hành,
đảm bảo hệ thống của mình hoạt động liên
tục.
Nó có thông tin nó có bị tấn công bị sai
thì mình phải phát hiện được nó bị mất
thì mình phải có cái dữ liệu backup để
mình khôi phục lại được rồi.
Ngoài ra thì mình sẽ có đương nhiên mình.
Các hả các hệ thống hiện tại của mình á?
Theo số hiện tại thì nó sẽ không hoạt
động theo kiểu dạng tỉnh mà thường sẽ
phải nằm trong một cái kết nối động với
nhau và chia sẻ thông tin liên tục với
nhau nên nó phải đầy đủ tất cả các hạ
tầng này và nó.
Phải được các cái lớp nhân lực này nó
phải.
Tham gia hỗ trợ và kết nối,
xử lý nhịp nhàng với nhau thì cái hạ tầng
của mình mới có thể mở rộng nhanh và tích
cực vận hành đáng tin cậy được.
Chỉ còn chứ nó không phải đơn giản là cho
em,
chỉ cần mua một cái mấy chủ rồi em cài
cái hệ thống phần mềm theo cái nhu cầu sử
dụng của mình là mình có thể vận hành
được nữa ha, nó phải đầy đủ 5 lớp này.
Và ngoài ra.
Thì cái.
Hạ tầng mà khi em xây dựng lên giống như
câu ví dụ hồi nãy á.
Là nó phải đi theo quy trình và nó phải
có cái vận hành đồ phù hợp với mô hình
kinh doanh.
Tôi phải đầy đủ 3 cái.
Đầy đủ các năng lực này,
cái hạ tầng em xây dựng ra mà nó không có
dữ liệu chuẩn,
nó không có một lo quy trình thống nhất
nào hết thì nó sẽ không vận hành được.
Cái này thì ngay cả CV chính quy,
các bạn cũng bị thiếu nữa.
Là các bạn khi học về web và ứng dụng di
động á là các bạn kêu các bạn xây dựng về
đồ án trong môn học thì các bạn hay có
cái thói quen là các bạn không có tìm
hiểu một quy trình và các bạn chỉ tìm
hiểu về kỹ thuật thôi.
Và thấy coi mình có sự.
Nhận được chức năng thêm xóa sửa cái gì
đó không như là xem thêm xóa sửa nhân
viên được không mà các em không quan tâm
tới cái quy trình quản lý nhân lực nhân
sự thật sự.
Rồi các chức năng mà các bạn thiết kế ra
nó có hợp lý hay không,
đôi khi các bạn quên luôn các bạn hay suy
nghĩ là thích tới các bạn hãy có xuống là
tách thử kỹ thuật.
á là thích chiếc năng gì thì các bạn sẽ
tải cái cân đó.
Thì cái này và thường nó là bị trừ điểm
nặng đối với sinh viên chuyên ngành,
mặc dù mấy bạn em nói là chính năng em
vẫn chạy được mà nhưng mà nó không theo
quy trình nào hết và nó không có.
Nó không vận hành được,
nó không tự động hóa đo lường mà mình
không giám sát được.
Và mình không có thể cái tái cấu trúc mà
mình thiết kế nó thông minh á thì sẽ bị
trừ điểm thôi.
Còn nếu mà công nghệ hạ tầng thông tin bị
yếu thì cái dữ liệu số hóa em có thể bị
dễ bị đứt gãy và nó có dễ bị chậm,
khó khó thích hợp ha dữ liệu không đáng
tin cậy. Cái này là người ta sợ lắm,
nuôi dữ liệu không đáng tin cậy.
Và bảo mật yếu ha.
Cái này nói chung là vấn đề nào đối với
một cái hạ tầng dữ liệu uy tín,
người ta đều phải đảm bảo đầy đủ các yếu
tố này.
Và.
Khi mà người ta xây dựng thì nó sẽ có cái
giải pháp quản trị đương nhiên mình phải
quản trị thì nó sẽ có 3 cái giải pháp
quản trị khác nhau.
Ha thì thường thì người ta **** muốn là
cái hệ thống mình phải ổn định,
kiểm soát chuẩn hóa tốt.
Nhưng mà phải đi kịp tốc độ linh hoạt
theo nhu cầu thị trường.
Nên hai cái này là hai cái vấn đề nó hay
thuận với nhau và mình phải cân ráng cố
gắng cân bằng đó.
Và về giải pháp quản trị hay dùng để cân
bằng hai yếu tố này là người ta có thể đi
theo mô hình này.
Là người chạy vừa cả tiếng,
vừa đổi mới rồi,
hoặc là đi theo kiến trúc doanh nghiệp,
rồi mình chuẩn hóa để nhanh mà mình không
có quá trình vận triển khai hệ thống của
mình, nó không bị loạn ha.
Là thực hiện tự động hóa, kiểm thử,
triển khai bảo mật để tăng tốc nhưng mà
vẫn kiểm soát tùy theo cái.
Nhu cầu và cái đội team đó người ta thích
cái nào,
cái này nó giống như là dựa trên góc nhìn,
người ta sẽ lựa chọn cái giải pháp phù
hợp với.
Và khi mà em xây dựng ra thì các em phải
đảm bảo rằng cái hạ tầng công nghệ thông
tin của em xây dựng ra nó giúp hiệu quả
cho tổ chức.
Tại vì nếu mà mình xong xây dựng tốt thì
nó sẽ tác động đến chi.
Chuyên vận hành với đến năng suất và chất
lượng dịch vụ và đến tốc độ đổi mới luôn
tốc độ phát triển của doanh nghiệp á nên
mình phải đảm bảo tất cả những cái hạ
tầng khi mà thiết kế ra nó hợp lý,
chi phí hợp lý.
Hỗ trợ năng suất và đảm bảo chất lượng
dịch vụ và nó có khả năng có tốc độ đổi
mới phù hợp.
Rồi khi mà người ta xây dựng một cái
thuyết minh đề tài và người ta **** muốn
đương nhiên đó là tất cả những cái gì mà
cái dự án mình muốn đạt tới,
nhưng mà làm sao mình kiểm soát nó thì
thường sẽ có các chỉ số.
KPI theo dõi về vận hành về chuyển đổi về
dữ liệu và an ninh thì mình sẽ phải đảm
bảo hết tất cả các chỉ số này.
Cái này tùy theo ha.
Nếu mà các em đi sâu về các cái bài toán
về dự án với mỗi bài toán nó sẽ có một
cái bộ chỉ số KPI theo dõi khác nhau.
Ninh Thuận là cô sẽ cho các bạn đi tìm
hiểu bài toán rồi mình đi tìm hiểu cái
chỉ số KP đi theo cái này nó giống như
các cái độ đo quy định vậy thôi em.
Ví dụ giống như nếu mà các bạn chưa có
quen học với chuyên ngành,
chưa có quen các độ đo về thiếu.
Rossivision of connect of thì các em có
thể xem nó giống như các điểm mà cô đưa
ra hồi nãy. Điểm đánh giá,
khả năng của em giống như em là dự án.
Ví dụ em là dự án.
Thầy làm sao cô biết em có thể đạt được
cái yêu cầu tiêu chuẩn kỹ thuật của vừa
đặt ra thì cô sẽ dùng điểm quá trình điểm
thực hành và điểm cuối kỳ thì đánh giá em.
Thì đó là 3 chỉ số đo lường để đánh giá
chỉ số theo dõi đánh giá em á thì mấy cái
chỉ số này nó cũng y chang như vậy.
Nó là các chỉ số đo lường để theo dõi cái.
Cơ xã từ máy thông tin hoặc là bảo kẻ
đang vận hành.
Nó có độ trễ hơn,
nó có tốn nhiều chi phí không?
Nó sẽ đo lường trên nhiều phát độ khác
nhau và mình phải đảm bảo rằng các chỉ số
đo lường của mình á khi mà mình đo ra kết
quả của nó là sẽ chứng minh được cái hệ
thống của mình.
Nó có vận hành đáng tin cậy nè.
Cái này buồn nó tạo ra cái nền tảng năng
lực chuyển đổi số tốt và cái hạ tầng của
em nó vận hành tốt.
An ninh nó có tích hợp,
có đầy đủ thông tin,
tích hợp có dữ liệu và quản trị ha và
mình chứng minh rằng cái hệ thống của
mình nó sẽ có cái hoạt động bền vững
trong vòng 5 đến 10 năm.
Thì em sẽ phải đảm bảo với đầy đủ tất cả
các yếu tố này,
là nó phải có hạ tầng tin cậy rồi có nền
tảng dùng chung để chia sẻ có dữ liệu
chuẩn,
rồi có tích hợp mọi dễ dàng tích hợp với
các công nghệ mới,
giao hàng nhanh ở đây có nghĩa là dev sức
ép này ốp hồi nãy á.
Và cái hạt tử này nè là cái quá trình
kiểm thử,
triển khai bảo mật của mình nó hoạt động
liên tục và nó không bị nghẽn á.
Rồi quản trị rủi ro tốt thì thường khi mà
làm với cái giai đoạn này đối với một cái
dự án thì người ta sẽ có một cái bản KPI
đo lường để người ta chứng minh tất cả
các điều nữa yếu tố này.
Giống như em nói cái hạ tầng,
hạ tầng của em nó sẽ có đầy đủ cái yếu tố
để giúp cho cái việc chuyển đổi số bền
vững.
Thì thường người ta có thể lập ra một cái
bảng định tính.
Tất cả các yếu tố về hạ tầng, về nền tảng,
về dữ liệu, về khả năng tích hợp,
về khả năng triển khai và quản trị rủi ro
và xét trên các nhiều tiêu chí mà người
ta sẽ xác định tính và kết hợp với các số
định lượng.
Các con số ở đường này,
ở đây là các con số định lượng nó có công
thức đo luôn giống như công thức của tính
điểm cho các em vậy đó.
Cô tính điểm quá trình cô sẽ thấy nhiều
cô cho các em 4 bài tập trên lớp thì cô
sẽ lấy 4 bài tập trên lớp đó.
Cô tính điểm và mỗi bài tập là 20 năm.
Tr gì?
25% và thay thang điểm 10 thì tính ra sẽ
ra cái điểm tổng cuối cùng của các em thì
nó sẽ có công thức tính.
Cái phần công thức tính này các em nhìn
thì thấy nó bây giờ mình mới đăng quang,
mình nhìn thấy nó nhiều,
có thể mình thấy nó lạ chứ thực chất nó
không có quá khó thôi.
Các em sẽ xem nó là một hệ chỉ là một
công thức và một độ đo đo một cái gì đó
thôi. Có thể giống như cô đơn.
Coi quá trình bình thường giống như cô
dùng 3 điểm,
cô đâu quá trình coi em nào quá trình học
tập trong lớp của em ổn không rồi cái bài
tập thực hành em đạt hơn,
bài tập đoàn của Việt Nam em đạt không
thì cái này nó cũng giống như cái độ đo.
Nó sẽ đo coi cái thời gian khi mà em ví
dụ em nói.
Thế là cái hệ thống của em vận hành tốt
và nó không có độ trễ và chi phí vận hành
ổn thì em sẽ đo cái chi phí vận hành
triển khai thời gian cái chi phí đầu tư
của em như thế nào ha.
Thì nó chỉ là cái đầu đo và nó có một đức
tính riêng và lát hồi cô sẽ cho các em
làm cái bài tập về ở nhà để mình tìm hiểu
về nó, ha nó cũng không quá khó.
Ngoài ra thì khi mà khi triển khai về
công nghệ thông tin trong hệ sinh thái,
ngoài năm lớp đó thì người ta có thể đánh
giá theo miền,
giống như là mình đo về mình quản trị,
vận hành, kinh doanh,
truyền thông và dịch vụ số.
Nó cũng sẽ có các miền kỳ vọng thì với
các miền kỳ vọng,
ví dụ quản trị thì mình **** muốn quản
trị cái thông tin,
các cái quy trình hoạt động của nó minh
bạch và chi phí rủi ro và lộ trình.
Có hệ thống trong quá trình vận hành thì
nó ổn định.
Kinh doanh thì đạt các mục tiêu giống như
em **** muốn là xây dựng các cái chức
năng hỗ trợ cho khách hàng và hay là tư
vấn dành cho sinh viên.
Khi em đặt các mục tiêu nào vậy thì các
cái hệ thống của mình nó xây dựng ra cái
hành nền tảng hạ tầng cái ứng đủ các hiệu,
các cái hạ tầng đó ha cái mục tiêu đặt ra
đó rồi có cái truyền thông.
Rồi có các cái kênh truyền thông để mình
quảng bá và các dịch vụ số sản phẩm số
tin cậy để cung cấp.
Thì với mỗi cái nó sẽ có cái công nghệ,
công nghệ thông tin,
nó sẽ cung cấp các cái thành phần khác
nhau và mình sẽ có các cái chỉ số KPI
chung để mình đo lường xem các thành phần
công nghệ thông tin của mình nó có đạt
yêu cầu.
Theo mình kỳ vọng này hay không thì cái
này nó làm một cái cách hiểu riêng ha,
có thể là theo cách hiểu này,
nhưng mà mình làm.
Không biết trồng cái môn của mình á thì
cô mình sẽ đi theo cái này nha em.
Hạ tầng tại vì nó đi theo có kiến trúc.
Trong ngành công nghệ thông tin của mình,
khi thiết kế triển khai người ta quan
trọng về kiến trúc để có thể giống như
các em kiến trúc giống như là xây nhà vậy
đó, các em phải có bản thiết kế.
Thì cái này nó giống như bạn thiết kế để
các em triển khai cái động tư,
ví dụ giống như trong khoa của mình đang
**** muốn xây dựng một phòng lab thí
nghiệm cho khoa.
Thì cái phòng lab của mình xây dựng đầu
tư hạ tầng thì các em phải có cái chiến
lược kiến trúc,
đầu tư hạ tầng phù hợp thì mình mới xin
kinh phí để mình đầu tư phòng lab.
Từ mua thiết bị tới các thành phần khác
nhau để cho cái hoạt động nghiên cứu của
phòng lab dành cho sinh viên của khoa
hoạt động tốt.
Thì đương nhiên nó không phải chỉ là sử
dụng cái theo phần mềm thôi.
Các em phải đưa ra cái chiến lược vận
hành miệng ứng dụng của mình và dành cho
vấn đề nghiên cứu trong lĩnh vực ngành
nào.
Ví dụ giống như các cái ngành quan trọng
ở trong khoa của mình.
Thường thì đi theo các nhóm nghiên cứu
thì có hiện tại thì có các nhóm nghiên
cứu về như B về BigDather rồi về
blockchain, về dữ liệu vi sinh,
dữ liệu audio, vân vân gì đó.
Nó sẽ có nhiều.
Cái và với mỗi mục tiêu mình đặt ra thì
mình phải xây dựng cái lab của mình phải
đầy đủ có những thành phần gì để có thể
đáp ứng được cái hạ tầng nghiên cứu và
cung cấp cho sinh viên ở tất cả các lĩnh
vực đó chẳng hạn.
Thì nó sẽ đi theo cái gói kiến trúc này
hơn thì mình mới xây dựng được ha.
Rồi đó là cái nội dung,
cái phần bài tạo nghe học nội dung cơ bản
về. Hôm nay còn về bối cảnh ứng dụng á,
thì ở đây cô cũng rất nhiều ha.
Hầu như ngành nào nó cũng đều có ứng dụng
công nghệ thông tin cả.
Rồi đó là cái nội dung phần hôm nay các
em có chỗ nào không rõ không?
Rồi nếu không có chỗ nào không rõ thì bây
giờ mình sẽ giao bài tập nha.
Bài tập công an xa slide này.
Đây là slide cốt lõi và mình sẽ thí dụ
kem xây dựng dự án lớn và dự án của mình
nó sẽ phải đầy đủ tất cả các thành phần
này.
Còn cái bài thực hành của mình là dự án
nhỏ thì các em có thể đi vô một cái.
Nhà mình,
nền tảng ứng dụng một cái phần mềm ứng
dụng cụ thể hoặc là kết hợp với cơ sở dữ
liệu của nó thôi nhỏ hơn,
ha thì trong cái slide này á?
Kem sẽ đi tìm hiểu về các cái lớp năng
lực này.
Chi tiết hơn rồi,
các em tìm hiểu về các khái niệm,
đây là mấy cái khái niệm mà bình thường.
Các em cần phải,
ví dụ như data center là gì, cloud là gì.
Các em tìm hiểu về khái niệm và vì sao
cái vai trò của nó trong cái hạ tầng công
nghệ.
Cũng tin nhiệm vụ bài tập của mình ơi vậy
ha, bây giờ cô sẽ ví dụ ha.
Cái câu Stop Saring đó là bài tập của
mình nha.
Bây giờ cô sẽ làm mẫu cho 1 nhóm,
thì bây giờ 1 mình sẽ làm bài tập như thế
nào thì hiện tại cô sẽ mở cái bài tập
chương 1 này lên nha các em.
cô coi.
Đất lai của mình ngày 20 tháng 7 rồi,
đến nay của mình ngày hôm nay hả tại mình
sẽ học đường link.
Kem và nhớ là kem nộp đường link và khi
trong quá trình học cái file của em đường
link của em thì nó được trên vai của em
thì trong quá sau khi sửa xong thì con
thấy em thấy cái bài đó cần chỉnh sửa thì
cô sẽ cho các em sửa chừng nào cô thông
báo là hết hạn chỉnh sửa.
Các bài tập trên lớp,
bài thực hành bắt đầu oán thì lúc đó mình
mới không cập nhật nữa thôi.
Còn không thì mình cứ cập nhật bình
thường, ha.
Cô khuyến khích cái em làm và cập nhật
bài của mình.
Giả sử đây là cái bài tập chương một.
Hôm nay của mình ha.
Thì các em vào đây,
các em sẽ thấy cái hướng dẫn yêu cầu là
đại diện nhóm mất lớp toàn bộ sản phẩm
trên Ry của nhóm MIS và lưu linh sản phẩm
vào fan của TT rồi nạp thẻ deadline là
ngày hôm nay.
Tại vì em còn 3 giờ để nộp á, giả sử.
Của cô là cậu đang ở nhóm 1 hả?
Ta nhóm 1 nha.
Rồi ở đây các em sẽ coi cái bài tập của
cô nè.
Bài tập chương 1 của mình sẽ nằm trong
cái chuỗi bài tập trên lớp.
Thì nó là cái bài tập lý thuyết trên lớp
là thế erry thì các em sẽ vô thư mục này.
Và cái tên còn bài tập thực hành thì bỏ
vô phân đơn thực hành,
đồ án luôn học thì bỏ vô đồ fonder đồ án
môn học thôi nhá.
Rồi bài tập trên lớp.
Thì em sẽ có bài tập chương một.
Thì kem cất bị đúng cái tên bài tập này.
Rồi vô đây kem tạo fonder.
Đúng cái fonder này luôn.
Rồi các em ngọc fonder này nha các em,
bây giờ ở đây các em copy đường link nè,
rồi các em đi cứ đi theo hướng dẫn đại
diện nhóm.
Em bỏ vô file word five tee,
ví dụ em bỏ vô file word và em đặt tên
cái file word hay tên nhóm cho cô dễ biết
nha em ghi tên là nhóm một rồi dán đường
lên file.
Dán thẳng cái đường link đó rồi đây vì
nhóm ngọc lên đây ra xong còn cái bài tập
thì các em có thể phân công các bạn và
các em làm và các em thí dụ các bạn phân
công công cái nội dung tài liệu cung cấp.
Gì đó thì kem có phân công,
các bạn làm riêng rồi em tổng hợp là phải
file phái no thì cái em cứ làm thẳng
trong fonder này.
Collid giữa đường link cô vô đây là cô sẽ
coi được và do cái em đã xem quyền lớn
cho cô rồi nên cô mặc định có quyền.
Nên kem không cần phải.
Xe cho cô.
Cái kem không cần phải share cái quyền
ngoại hết.
Và sau này cô là quần áo nữa đây nữa.
Ở Hà Quỳnh, cô cái này con cho cô mở cô,
cô tạo nên cô đang tạo nên cô là.
Đó là cách nhận bài tập.
Các dấu hiệu hiểu rõ chưa?
Nếu mà cô tạo sẵn rồi thì bây giờ các em
chỉ cần copy cái đường link fonder này
rồi nộp trên earning là được. Hiểu không?
Nhóm 1.
Nếu 1 nhóm này đến trường chúng ta.
Bạn Sơn hiểu không em,
cách làm bài tập chưa?
Anh em hiểu của tôi.
Ok rồi,
còn bài tập mình làm gì thì còn nhắc lại.
Bài tập của mình là.
Tìm hiểu các khái niệm cơ bản.
Và cái vai trò của nó.
Các em sẽ viết một cái báo cáo tìm hiểu
về vai trò của nó ở đây.
Ở đây số 10 tìm hiểu các khái niệm cơ bản
và các vai trò của nó. Rồi đó là câu,
đó là ý thứ nhất.
Cái thứ 2 của mình.
Thì các em sẽ.
Tìm hiểu về các cái độ đo ha các độ đo.
Gửi ở đây.
Để em xem coi mấy cái độ đo này nghĩa là
gì, công thức tính nó là gì ha?
Đây là các bộ chỉ số nên theo dõi có thể
nó là công thức hoặc là cách thức để đo
lường nó.
Các em có thể tìm hiểu các bộ chỉ số này
và các bộ chỉ số KPI bên đây.
Cái này cũng show lắm,
đây cũng là một số cái cây trời ơi,
chỉ số độ đo lường mà thường người ta hay
dùng á.
Thì các em tìm hiểu để mình biết con máy
đó là gì ha được không?
Rồi để đây cô viết lại trong cái phần
hướng dẫn để bổ sung luôn.
Trước đây có một số các bạn.
Quên không biết tính nam hữu rồi ở đây là
các em sẽ tìm hiểu. Thứ nhất,
các bài tập tìm hiểu các khái niệm.
Và vai trò
Của các thành phần trong lớp năng lực ở
hạ tầng công nghệ thông tin.
Trong các lớp,
trong 5 lớp năng lực của hạ tầng công
nghệ thông tin.
Rồi cái thứ 2 là các em sẽ tìm hiểu về
các KPI tại muốn mình viết thuyết minh đề
tài á khi mà em hướng là em sẽ sử dụng
các KPI này để em hiện thực hóa lời hứa
của em với ví dụ giống như em nói là.
Xây dựng trong một cái hệ thống khuyến
nghị có độ chính xác cao.
Trên 70% cái đó nó phải có số liệu cụ thể
chứ mình không có thể sử dụng một cái từ
định tính,
nó không có số liệu đo lường để mình viết
viết mình.
Và người ta nó không có không biết cái
thế nào nên muốn nghiệm thu để tạ được
nha.
Em phải có chỉ số rõ ràng để nghiệm thu á
ha thì các em tìm hiểu về các cái bộ chỉ
số thay đổi hoặc là các.
KPI đo lường mới có nhiều cách gọi ha.
Thì nó cũng sẽ là các khái niệm,
tìm hiểu khái niệm.
Vai trò,
vai trò nó dùng cái đầu đó đi để làm cái
gì và cách thức đo lường.
Đo lường các cái KPI,
các cái bộ chỉ số và cây ở Salai 14 và
các cái KPI Salai 16 cái.
Rồi đó là cái phần bài tập ngày hôm nay.
Rồi nhóm trưởng nhóm.
Tình nhiên sao mấy cái cô danh sách lớp
này.
Đây nếu 11 bạn quan hiểu yêu cầu bài tập
ngày hôm nay cho em.
Mà gặp chương 1.
Ờ dạ nhưng mà hoàn thành trong lúc học
này luôn hay là để sau cũng được.
Hoàn thành tới buổi sau,
cô sẽ sửa bài bài tập mình theo cách học
của mình,
cô sẽ cho học hết lý thuyết và cô cho bài
tập,
và cô sẽ cho các em thời gian làm bài tập
trong tuần. Tới tuần,
buổi tiếp theo mình sẽ sửa bài.
Cô sẽ một nhóm bất kỳ để sửa bài.
Dạ vâng, em cảm ơn.
Nhưng mà đừng linh nộp là phải nộp trong
ngày hôm nay nha em.
Các em nộp lên rồi cái file,
còn cái file quá trình làm này kem có thể
làm trực tiếp lên right và đến thời hạn
mà cô không cho cập nhật nữa thì mới là
deadline dừng được không? Thế cô nói luôn.
Nếu 11 bạn gì ta?
Chả hiểu hiểu.
À quay.
Các nhóm khác.
Rồi nếu không có vấn đề gì nữa thì vậy
buổi học của mình sẽ kết thúc ở đây ha
Con này coi coi coi.
sao em?
Dạ thôi cho em hỏi là cái link đó nó đã
có kết quả chưa,
hay là nó chỉ là một cái link trước thôi?
Cái link fonder trước thôi em để kêu kiểm
tra tại cái cô lúc mà cô chấm bài của các
À vậy.
em là cô sẽ lên Bride,
cô kiểm tra trực tiếp luôn.
Nhưng mà bên trung tâm người ta cần phải
quản lý các bài tập.
Để kiểm soát á nên cái đường link này nộp
để cho bên trung tâm kiểm tra đó.
À dạ, cảm ơn cô ạ.
Ừ ừ.
Với lại một phần là do cái hệ thống lưu
trữ bên trên eelanin của mình không có
nhiều lắm nên cô mới mình mới dùng lưu
trên Bride để nộp đường link để giảm tải
cái.
Cái không gian lưu trữ cho cái trang web
của hệ thống bên trung tâm.
Sao Trần.
Dạ,
anh em hiểu cái phần độc hại là một hạng
một bài trong nhóm là thôi,
còn các hành viên còn lại thì không còn
nộp hả cô?
Đúng rồi em, đại diện nhóm nào?
Cảm ơn cô.
Ủa nhưng mà sao em vô nộp thử thì nó lại
bắt em tải tập tin ta.
Em nộp cho em.
Dạ ý là em gửi cái đường link vô trước á
em đọc đường link trước á.
Em nộp đường link,
em phải lưu nó vô file word rồi em upload
file lên em hệ thống nó không cho em nộp
link không đâu.
Thấy không?
À rồi rồi pass cái link vô trong một cái
file xong em gửi cái file đó lên là được
đúng không?
Đúng rồi, đặt theo tên nhóm mình nha.
Em thấy vừa em đặt tên nhóm 1 thì cô nhìn
vô cái file mới cô biết là nhóm một đọc
bài thấy vừa thầy cô bên trung tâm như
kiểm tra con biết là bài tập lên sản phẩm
của nhóm một.
Còn cái tên bài tập không cần nha.
Tại vô cái thằng sidment thì biết bài tập
nào rồi.
Rồi siêu sao em?
Em em cũng giống bạn đi.
Điều em biết cách làm rồi đúng không?
Rất chưa, nhưng mà.
Rồi vậy tắt tắt giơ tay để em có biết
không? Rồi tới minh sao minh?
Ở nhà cô cho em hỏi là.
Mình có học bù với tuần trước luôn của
mình.
Học bầu là cô sẽ phải dài đủ hết 8 mũi.
Thay vì mình sẽ kết thúc từ đằng trước.
Học 8 mũi liên tục thì cô sẽ dạy trễ thêm
thêm 1 tuần nữa để bù vô.
Này cô sẽ tại vì cô sẽ bù vô đúng cái
nghề này luôn chứ không có bù sang mũi
khác bù sang mũi khác rồi bị dễ bị trùng
giờ lắm.
cảm ơn.
Mình học làm sao đủ 8 buổi thì mình mới
dừng thế?
Sao không?
À coi nhóm 7,
tụi em có gửi lại lên drive cô.
Giống vậy rồi.
Em có đến đây đúng không?
Nhảy ra đúng không ạ?
Cái này đúng không em?
Tạo thiếu cột process rồi đó em.
Rồi cô cập nhật giống vậy à,
cô sẵn đây cô quên hết kem tạo cho cô cái
file she.
Bản phân công công việc ha.
Cái pha xít này là cô cho các em tự do
lựa chọn.
Thiết kế miễn sao nó đạt được các tiêu
chí sau là được.
Cô ví dụ.
Ở đây,
ví dụ đây là một cái file ship file đang
kế hoạch và bản phân công công việc của
các bạn,
miễn sao trên cái file ship đó của các em
có đầy đủ thông tin các thành viên trong
nhóm.
Phàm,
các em có thể đánh giá được mức độ hoàn
thành theo 3 cột điểm của mình qua bài
tập trên lớp nè, đâu bán và thực hành ha.
Em các em có thể giống như các bạn tạo ra
một cái quy định riêng cho nhóm của mình
cái này tùy khác nhóm ha.
Cô không có xác định quy định chính thức
của các em xác định quy định phải như thế
nào tại vì cái này là tùy theo cái vận
hành của mỗi nhóm thì các em đặt ra cái
quy định mà các em có thể kiểm soát thành
viên mức độ hoàn thành các thành viên của
nhóm.
Thành ra được.
Sau đó là các em sẽ có các cái cột tương
ứng cho 3 thành phần cột điểm.
Ví dụ cột quá trình là các em sẽ có cái
thí dụ bài tập giống như bài tập chương
một.
Chương 1 rồi, các em có các công việc nào?
Rồi cái em giao,
các bạn làm cái gì em giao các bạn làm và
các bạn làm được các gì á thì các bạn sẽ
thống kê các cái nội dung cơ bản và các
bạn thực hiện ở trên đây.
Xong rồi có link tới cái,
có thể ở đây các bạn ở đây cô không có
yêu cầu linh.
Slide tài liệu tham khảo nha,
cô chỉ yêu cầu các bạn lên tới cái file
sản phẩm thôi để cô chấm.
Còn ở đây thì các bạn muốn thì cái bạn
giám trưởng các bạn nó sẽ để các slide
tài liệu sẵn luôn để cho các bạn mà làm
cái nhiệm vụ này á.
Bạn dễ coi có deadline này,
ha rồi giao cho ai nè rồi trạng thái nè,
kết quả thực chất là cô chỉ cần kết quả
này để cô coi.
Với lại cái nội dung tóm tắt.
Ví dụ bạn đã làm xong rồi bạn đã làm cái
gì để?
Đã tóm tắt những nội dung thực hiện được
để cô kiểm tra nhanh.
Đây là cái mức đánh giá rồi cái điểm đánh
giá của các bạn.
Cái này tại vì mỗi nhóm các em sẽ có cái
mức đánh giá và thang điểm thì có các bạn
có thể xét theo kiểu là mỗi ship.
Tạm bỏ vòng đâu một tax.
Là kết thúc một điểm,
còn nếu mà có nhóm không thích thì cô nhớ
có nhớ đánh trọng số được tùy theo các em,
thí dụ công việc đó nặng thì trọng số cao
hơn, điểm cao hơn thì dựa trên mấy cái đó,
các em sẽ tiến hành thống kê các cái cột
bên này cũng vậy thôi à.
Tương tự,
em có thể là một cái sử dụng chung.
Rồi, miễn sao khi mà với mỗi bạn á,
các em có thể tiến hành thống kê,
đánh giá được KP riêng,
đóng góp của từng bạn rồi các em sẽ có.
Nếu mà các em đánh giá riêng được rồi thì
các em sẽ có cái ship thống kê và các em
sẽ vẽ được cái biểu đồ mức đồ hoàn thành
của từng bạn nữa.
Nguyễn cái file bản phân công công việc
của các bạn,
của các em làm được cái này là được.
Rồi các em muốn thiết kế như thế nào thì
từ các em không có giới hạn cái khâu
thiết kế của mình hết.
Miễn đạt được những yêu cầu đó là được.
Hiểu không, nhưng mà.
Nếu 10 bạn bích.
Biết cách tạo khoản phân công công việc
chưa em.
Bắt
Dạ.
Dạ, anh nghe rồi ạ.
Hình dung các bạn thì cái em mà nhóm
trưởng là em sẽ thiết kế cái bản phân
công công việc hoặc là em có thể các bạn
nhóm trưởng muốn xem thẻ công việc á chọn
một bạn thử ký.
Nhà bạn đăng ký làm phân công,
anh ký làm cái này thống kê cái này,
còn nhóm trưởng thì kiểm tra sản phẩm.
Cái này tùy theo nhóm mình làm hay thường
thường thì trong một cái tổ thì mình sẽ
có một trưởng nhóm,
một thư ký khoa học và các thành viên
tham gia.
Em có thể chọn một bạn nào đó kỹ tính nằm
thư ký thống kê cái này để còn được hết
luôn hả các em?
Còn file này cô sẽ không cho hết mọi nhóm
tự thiết kế của mình đi.
Rồi nếu không có vấn đề gì thì nhắc lại
các nhóm trưởng,
nhớ tạo folder và nộp link cho bài tập
ngày hôm nay cùng với mở trên eLining.
Sau đó rồi mình có bắt đầu tạo một buổi
hợp nhóm rồi.
Tao vẫn và công công việc và phân công
các công việc cho các bạn làm cái bài tập
này,
bài tập này đơn giản thôi ha chỉ là tìm
hiểu các khái niệm về các cái thành phần
trong lớp năng lực. Với các KPI,
ý nghĩa của các KPI đo lường là được.
Rồi nếu không có vấn đề gì nữa thì buổi
học của mình sẽ kết thúc ở đây hả kim?
Có gì ở Phong?